est totalement écartée celle de
Tchernobyl semble désormais plus
probable voilà pour ce sujet de Mathilde
terrier alors on va tout de suite
rejoindre Fernand tavarz qui est
toujours en direct de la salle la
Martine alors Fernand nous l'avons vu
mais alors est-ce que ces événements
dramatiques qui se passent au Japon
peuvent modifier la stratégie du
gouvernement en matière nucléaire ça va
être la question qui va être abordorderé
cet après-midi mais tout de suite vous
êtes avec une nouvelle invitée c'est
Madame Vautrin madame catherrine Varin
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale qui
évidemment est mobilisée comme
l'ensemble des parlementaires députés et
sénateurs qui se sont pressés Sala
Martine pour écouter et interroger
surtout tous les responsables de la
filière nucléaire française Nathalie
cossusco morisé et ériic Besson sont
également sur place madame Vautrain
est-ce que la situation nucléaire en
France vous préoccupe est-ce qu'il faut
vraiment faire toute la carté est-ce que
vous êtes prête à aller éventuellement
sur le terrain et exiger des uns et des
autres que tout soit vraiment dit le
Premier ministre ministre l'a dit de
façon extrêmement claire depuis
maintenant plus de 24 heures il est
absolument indispensable bien évidemment
que l'on regarde la situation française
mais il est également très important que
nous travaillons sur un autre élément
qui est le retour d'expérience au Japon
les choses évoluent d'heure en heure
pour ne pas dire de minute en minute
donc il est logique que nous prenions
toutes les dispositions et je crois que
la Commission de cet après-midi est la
bienvenue parce que elle va nous
permettre de faire un point avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'Autorité de
sûreté en passant par le gouvernement et
par les principaux professionnels du suj
les Français sont-ils trop inquiets
quant à la situation de nos centrales
nucléaires ou pas vous savez là comme
ailleurs je crois qu'il faut que nous
gardions notre sang frroid pour autant
il est logique que nous soyons tous
préoccupés eugard à l'ampleur de ce qui
se passe au Japon donc de la
responsabilité et du sang- frroid c'est
je crois les deux mots qui nous
caractérisent aujourd'hui merci
Catherine vre voilà Anaïs bien écouté la
salle est archi archi comble comme vous
l'avez vu et la séance commence très
bien voilà on rejoint tout de suite la
salle la Martine où vous allez suivre en
direct cette réunion très très attendu
sur la filière nucléaire et on se
retrouve tout de suite après bonne
audition président de la commission de
l'économie et du développement durable
du Sénat et Bruno sidau premier
vice-président de l'Office Parlementaire
je les remercie je crois que c'est ici
le Parlement rassemblé qui souhaite
écouter les ministres et les responsable
du milieu nucléaire pour faire le point
de la situation au Japon et pour pour
faire le point sur la situation et
l'organisation de la sûreté dans nos
propres
centrales un mot de Serge Poignant
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
moi aussi je voudrais saluer madame le
ministre monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues présidents
mesdames messieurs les députés mesdames
Messieurs les
Présidents pour avoir bien voulu
répondre à notre invitation à cette
audition commune au niveau au niveau de
ma commission des affaires économiques
nous avions souhaité très vite avoir une
audition donc je me réjouis de l' faire
de façon commune avec mes collègues et
en particulier avec l'Office dont on
connaît les travaux et les compétences
en matière de sécurité et de sûreté
nucléaire à la commission des affaires
économiques nous sortons d'une série
d'auditions sur le nucléaire la filière
nucléaire plutôt sur le côté industriel
stratégique effectivement mais nous
avonsuditionné les autorités de sécurité
D
ASN IRSN
et je moi je puis témoigner du fait que
nous sommes convaincus que depuis une
dizaine d'années nous avons en France
une structuration de sûreté de sécurité
nucléaire assez
exceptionnelle donc nous sommes très
intéressés par vous entendre
euh Mame madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre moi je je aujourd'hui je pense
comme l'a dit le Premier ministre hier
au question d'actualité il y aura un
moment pour le retour d'expérience il y
aur un moment pour le débat il nous faut
et c'est ainsi que je l'entends
personnellement avoir le maximum
d'information objective sur ce qui s'est
passé à à Fukushima sur ce que la
comparaison entre les centrales
japonaises et nos centrales françaises
nos réacteurs au bouillantes au
pressciurisé confinement et avoir le
maximum d'information à la fois pour
l'ensemble de nos collègues
parlementaires et pour concitoyens je
crois que c'est le temps aujourd'hui
d'avoir cette information c'est pour
cela que vous toutes et tous je vous
invite à poser le maximum de questions
nous avons voulu que ces que ces
auditions soient télévisées justement
pour qu'elles soi accessiblebl au plus
grand nombre alors merci ce n'est pas le
temps de la polémique ou ou de tel ou
tel débat qui ne soit pas dans
l'information c'est bien l'information
qui compte et que vous nous apportiez le
maximum d'éléments à la fois sur ce qui
s'est passé et sur les comparaisons
possibles avec la France merci merci
Serge avant de donner la parole à Serge
groard je rappellerai que cette
audition permettra après l'expression
des ministres d'abord l'expression des
porte-paroles des groupes parlementaires
les réponses des ministres et que
ensuite chacun pourra intervenir y
compris les autorités de sûreté les
soutiens scientifiques et techniques et
tous ceux qui sont autour de la Serge
gro merci monsieur le Président à mon
tour je voudrais me me joindre à vos
propos pour bien sûr nous nous associer
à la peine aux difficultés au drames que
vivent nos amis japonais et pour saluer
la dignité dont ils font preuve
actuellement et qui est
impressionnante dans la logique de ce
que vient de dire serge Poignant nous
souhaitons effectivement que cette
audition soit le lieu de réponse à des
questions les plus précises possibles et
que nous puissions effectivement faire
le point de la situation
actuellement pour amorcer le débat je
dirais que de mon point de vue il y a
trois types de questions qui se
posent le premier type de
question dont on a peu entendu parler
jusqu'à
présent quelle est la la configuration
nucléaire et notamment sur le site de
Fukushima 1 puisqu'on parle bien de ce
site là principalement peut-être pas
exclusivement mais principalement type
de centrale élément technique nous avons
besoin de disposer autant que faire ce
peu d'éléments techniques et les
spécialistes sont là pour apporter des
réponses à la représentation nationale
mais à travers elle à l'ensemble de de
nos concitoyens la deuxè de question
bien sûr qui se pose c'est aujourd'hui
quelle est la situation aux
abords du site de Fukushima 1 dans un
environnement immédiia quelle est la
situation précisément autant que faire
ce peut bien sûr et la troisème question
bien sûr au-delà pour l'ensemble du
territoire japonais et puis pour
l'ensemble par dérivée successive pour
l'ensemble de la planète et bien sûr de
nos concitoyens quelles sont les
hypothèses à ce jour en étant le plus
rigoureux et le plus le plus précis
possible quels sont les scénarios que
nous pouvons
envisager merci Serge nul autre que
l'Office Parlementaire n'était mieux
placé pour réunir députés et sénateurs
je cède maintenant la parole à Jean-Paul
etemorine oui merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre mesdames Messieurs les
Présidents mes chers collègues cette
réunion excep in de nos deux assemblées
doit d'abord nous permettre d'affirmer
solennellement notre solidarité avec le
peuple japonais la première des
priorités pour la France d'apporter au
Japon toute l'aide possible aussi bien
humanitaire que technique nous nous
préoccupons tout particulièrement du
sort de nos ressortissants au Japon et
nous suivrons de près l'évolution de la
radioactivité dans les territoir
français du Pacifique dans le cas où les
rejets dans l'atmosphère serait de
nature à faire porter une menace de
contamination sur ces territoires nous
attendons donc en premier lieu des
intervenants qu'il nous présente une
analyse la plus précise possible compte
tenu des nombreuses incertitudes
entourant une situation qui évolue
d'heure en heure de la situation
nucléaire au Japon les informations sur
les phénomènes précis qui surviennent
dans le cœur des réacteurs semblent
arriver avec retard les autorités
nucléaires japonaises ont-ell le
contrôle de la situation il est
également ement primordial de répondre
aux inquiétudes légitimes de nos
compatriotes s'agissant de la sûreté
nucléaire sur notre territoire les
centrales nucléaires françaises qui
bénéficient d'une grande homogénéité
font l'objet de visite régulière par
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui est
indépendante afin de vérifier de
rehausser le niveau de sécurité les
nouveaux programmes de construction de
centrale privilégie par-dessus tout la
sécurité des réacteurs quel qu'en soit
le coût financier les intervenants
peuvent-ils donc nous confirmer ici le
très haut niveau de sécurité exigé du
parc nucléaire pour pour autant il est
indispensable de préserver le lien de
confiance entre nos concitoyens et notre
secteur nucléaire j'approuve donc les
annonces faites d'ors et déjà par le
Premier ministre devant l'Assemblée
nationale les centrales français seront
contrôlés et les résultats seront rendus
publics voilà Mesdames Messieurs rap
rapidement ce que je voulais dire à cet
instant au moment où le débat va
s'ouvrir Bruno avait une question pour
lancer le débat
oui je voudrais naturellement m'associer
à tous mes collègues qui qui pensent et
qui accompagnent le peuple japonais oui
puisque c'est une affaire qui est
internationale par définition puisque
elle ne concerne pas seulement
principalement certes mais pas seulement
les Japonais je voudrais connaître la la
possibilité de coopération
internationale dans l'aide et la gestion
de cette crise
et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs nous avons
invité je vous remercie monsieur le
Président Monsieur etchavari qui est
directeur général de l'Agence de l'OCDE
pour l'énergie je pense qu'il y a une
dimension internationale qui n'échappe à
personne bien entendu et j'aimerais bien
qu'il participe au débat et nous apporte
sa contribution merci Bruno madame
monsieur le
ministre je laisse le
gouvernement choisir qui s'exprime en
premier sur quel sujet je je suis qu'un
petit parlementaire
donc monsieur le Président de l'Office
Claude birau mesdames Messieurs les
Présidents des commission Serge poignon
Serge Grouard Jean-Paul et morine
mesdames et messieurs parlementaires
nous venons avec Éric besesson vous
rendre compte aujourd'hui la situation
du nucléaire au Japon et et dans notre
pays je vrais saluer tous les présents
et en particulier ceux qui nous
accompagnent beaucoup de leur expertise
en ce moment andréco de la CSE le
président de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire ainsi qu'aniè bu
jacquespussard présidente et directeur
de l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire et Bernard Bigot
l'administrateur général du Commissariat
à l'énergie
atomique parlons donc du Japon où vient
d'avoir lieu une catastrophe dont les
conséquences sont sont loin d'être
encore connus entièrement et nous
parlerons aussi de la France où cette
catastrophe suscite des inquiétudes
auquel il faut
répondre le Japon a été frappé d'un
séisme d'une magnitud
neuf dévastateur avec un bilan humain
que que vous connaissez et comme vous le
savez ce séisme et surtout le tsunami
qui l'a suivi ont entraîné de très
graves difficultés sur la sûreté de
certains réacteurs japonais le la
réaction des réacteurs au séisme a
semble-t-il été telle qu'elle avait été
prévu le système d'arrêt
automatique de la réaction nucléaire des
différents réacteurs il y en a une
dizaine qui sont concerné a bien
fonctionné après le tremblement de terre
mais le tsunami a provoqué très graves
dommag dans les systèmes de
refroidissement de différents réacteurs
or un réacteur arrêté doit encore être
refroidi et ce pendant plusieurs
semaines plusieurs réacteurs de la
centrale se sont retrouvés privés d'eau
de refroidissement ceci a entraîné une
fusion partielle du cœur au moins
semble-t-il dans le réacteur numéro 1
réacteur numéro 2 et le réacteur numéro
3 de la centrale de Fukushima
Daishi de surcroix et et c'est peut-être
le point le plus important l'enceinte
d'un des réacteurs numéro 2 probablement
de deux puisqu'il y aurait aussi le
numéro 3 ont été
endommagés ceci entraîne véritableement
vraisemblablement des rejets radioactifs
continu qui qui viennent s'ajouter qui
sont bien entendu du du N autre nature
d'une plus grande ampleur une plus
grande gravité qui viennent s'ajouter au
rejet
radioactif
volontaire qui avait été
euh opéré par les agents de la centrale
pour faire diminuer la pression dans le
cœur des réacteurs après l'entrée en
fusion partielle de certains d'entre eux
des inquiétudes portent également sur
une piscine contenant du combustible usé
dans laquelle les les autorités
cherchent à apporter de l'eau pour
éviter que les combustibles se
retrouvent à nu là aussi ces
combustibles occurrence sont pas des
combustibles actifs mais mais ils ont
pas pour autant d'activité au sens
nucléaire ils doivent rester
ennoyés sinon ils se dégradent et
pourrait provoquer une émission directe
de radioactivité dans l'environnement
d'autant plus que ils ne sont pas eux
dans une partie confinée de la centrale
dans ce contexte entre les émissions
intentionnelles pour diminuer la
pression dans les réacteurs confinés les
émissions éventuellement permanentes qui
pourraient être lié au déconfinement de
certains réacteurs et par ailleurs la
dégradation probable du combustible dans
les piscines tout ceci provoque une
émission de radioactivité dans
l'environnement et une radioactivité
locale euh forte la majorité des
personnels de la centrale a été évacué
alors il y a eu retour semble-t-il de
certaines certains personnels puis à
nouveau évacuation et selon les
informations don nous disposons les
conditions d'intervention de la
centrales sont extrêmement difficiles
euh et et quand je dis difficile les les
euh les opérateurs qui sont restés du
sur place prennent des risques euh pour
leur santé et et manifestement pour leur
vie à ce stade les rejets de
radioactivité sont concentrés dans un
environnement relativement proche de la
centrale dans une zone de 20 km autour
de la centrale et et la radioactivité
diminue graduellement à partir du
site même dans cette configuration là il
y a des rejets atmosphériques qui
peuvent aller plus loin le 15 mars les
vents étent orientés vers Tokyo ils ont
entraîné une hausse de la radioactivité
qui était mesurable à Tokyo hausse qui
restait néanmoins à ce stade à des
niveaux faibles sans risque
sanitaire évidemment cette situation
conttetenu de de ce que j'ai dit
auparavant est susceptible de se
dégrader de se dégrader parce que donc
certains des réacteurs sont déconfinés
de se dégrader parce que l'eau peut
baisser dans les piscines de combustible
usagés de se dégrader aussi parce que
les opérateurs
qui agissent je redis dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
c'est le mot qu'utilisait la présidente
de l'IRSN en réponse à une question hier
probablement héroïque ces opérateurs ne
pourront peut-être pas continuer
longtemps dans ces conditions et il est
possible qu'un un moment certaines des
opérations de refroidissement qui sont
menées par exemple sur le réacteur
numéro 1 ou sur un réacteur qui n'est
pas encore déconfiné puisse à leur tour
ne plus être mené entraînant des
réactions en chaîne parce que les
opérateurs n'auront plus été en
condition physique de de mener ces
ces
ces ENF de prendre ces mesures autrement
dit la situation aujourd'hui est déjà
très grave et elle peut
s'aggraver fortement une forme de
réaction en chaîne que vous comprenez
bien dans dans le contexte des
précisions que j'ai pu donner je suppose
que nous aurons l'occasion dans les
questions de revenir sur la situation
des Français au Japon nous avons
recommandé aux Français qui n'avaient
pas d'excellente raison de rester à
Tokyo et cont tenu par ailleurs euh de
tous les problèmes auquels les autorités
japonaises avaient à faire face de
quitter le Japon ou si ne souhaitait pas
quitter le Japon de partir vers le sud
et par ailleurs à titre préventif des
pastill diode ont été distribué aux
Français euh il leurit toutefois
recommandé euh de ne rien absorber euh
dans la en l'absence de de d'instruction
euh de la part des autorités japonaises
euh et et les niveaux de radioactivité
je le redis qui ont été mesurés à Tokyo
ne ne ne ne pour le moment ne présent
pas de risque sanitaire un mot aussi sur
le Pacifique et les territoires
d'outrmer la radioactivité libérée
jusqu'à présent euh n'a ne n'a pas euh
d'effet euh devrait pas avoir de
conséquences sanitaires sur des
territoires situés à très grande
distance les territoires français du
Pacifique Sud sont pour les premiers à
7000 km mais cette conclusion rassurante
elle n'est déduite pour le que sur la
base de la radioactivité qui a été
libéré jusqu'à présent donc nous devons
rester extrêmement vigilant euh nous
ferons évaluer cette appréciation en en
permanence avec l'aide de l'Institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
qui possède un réseau de 163 balises de
surveillance réparties sur tout le
territoire il y en a une à Tahiti je
précise que les données sont disponibles
sur le site de
l'ursn l'IRSN modélise aussi et c'est
indispensable contenu des rejets massifs
de radioactivité auxquels il faut
s'attendre cont tenu du du scénario
possible et même probable que je
décrivait tout à l'heure l'IRSN modélise
aussi l'évolution du Panach radioactif
afin de prévoir son déplacement le
public en sera naturellement tenu
informé tant en métropole qu'en outrem
ainsi que pour tous les Français rés
à l'étranger et s'il était nécessaire
des mesures seraient prises là aussi
pour
eux voilà la synthèse on pourra
évidemment rentrer dans le le détail
mais mais mais j'attends nous attendons
pour ça vos question voilà pour le Japon
un mot quelques mots même sur la sûreté
nucléaire dans notre pays et en
métropole puisque naturellement ces
événements ont soulevé des
inquiétudes sur notre système national
alors nous sommes organisés depuis la
loi sur la transparence et la sécurité
nucléaire de 2006 que vous avez voté
avec des outils puissant en matière de
sûreté et de transparence nucléaire
c'est une organisation qui s'appuie sur
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui est
une autorité administrative indépendante
qui est le gendarme du nucléaire en
France l'autorité contrôle les sites
nucléaires elle impose des prescriptions
aux exploitants qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à la fermeture en cas de risque
grave l'autorité s'appuie sur
l'expertise de l'IRSN dont les budgets
dont les experts sont internationalement
reconnus l'IRSN a un budget plus de 300
millions d'euros avec 1600 personnes
d'importants Programm de recherche IRSN
est ainsi à la fois expert pour la
France et source de proposition au
niveau national et international et un
élément de réponse à la question de
Bruno silo tout à l'heure nous avons
proposé au gouvernement japonais
l'expertise de l'IRSN pour l'assister
dans le drame auquel il doit faire face
dans notre système stème de transparence
nationale le moindre incident fut-til
minime doit être signalé
systématiquement à l'ASN ça n'est pas
l'opérateur qui décide si
l'incident a une importance s'il est
pertinent ou pas de le signaler non il
est signalé automatiquement
systématiquement à l'ASN qui évalue qui
qualifie l'importance de ces incidents
qui les rend publ tous dans des délais
très courts et qui éventuellement en
tire des conclusions pour des mises à
niveau des centrales en matière de
sûreté et puis c'était prévu dans la loi
2006 aussi nous sommes dotés d'un Haut
Comité pour la transparence et
l'information sur la sécurité nucléaire
il est présidé par le sénateur honoraire
Henri Revol que je salue il s'agit d'un
organe collégial qui est chargé
d'améliorer l'information auprès du
grand public notamment du côté de la
conception des
centrales la sûreté est est organisé en
fait des des
l'origine puisque les différents risques
naturels majeurs auxquels une c centrale
peut être soumise en fonction de son
lieu d'implantation doivent être pris en
compte comme le risque sismique le
risque inondation si au cours du temps
les connaissances scientifiques
réévaluent le risque à la hausse alors
l'ASN demande des améliorations à
l'exploitant pour y faire face et ces
échanges et ce suivi peuvent bénéficier
et bénéficier dans ce cas à l'ensemble
des
centrales ça s'est fait sur différentes
occasions par exemple la centrale du
Blayet après la tempête de
1999 hauteur de vague avait été
insuffisamment anticipé et de la même
manière l'ASN doit tirer les leçons de
la tempête de xintia en ce qui concerne
le risque de submersion marine et ceci
peut conduire à des mises à niveau sur
l'ensemble des
centrales un mot sur le choix nucléaire
et le contexte
européen la France a fait choix
l'électricité nucléaire pour des raisons
d'indépendance énergétique tout autant
que pour des raisons technologiques
c'est un choix qui s'inscrit dans un
bouquet qui évolue aujourd'hui vers de
plus en plus d'énergies renouvelable
avec un objectif de 23 % d'énergie
renouvelable en 2020 et et nous
n'oublions pas dans ce contexte et je
vous invite à y penser aussi que
l'énergie la plus sûre est celle qu'on
ne consomme pas c'est un des enjeux du
Grenel de l'environnement la réduction
globale de notre consommation
énergétique ceci dit ce ce choix la
pertinence de ce bouquet repose dans la
durée sur une exigence absolue en
matière de sûreté nucléaire le
commissaire européen à l'énergie
monsieur tinger a proposé des tests de
résistance dans toutes les centrales
nucléaires européennes sur la base
d'accords volontaires un groupe deiveau
doit se réunir en avril sur des critères
et des normes qui tiendront compte de ce
qui s'est passé au Japon et à la lumière
de ses travaux le Premier ministre l'a
annoncé la France procédera en toute
évaluation en toute transpar ence à une
évaluation de sûreté de chaque réacteur
pour voir comment chacun d'eux et pour
pouvoir le rendre
public résiste réagit face à des
événements comme un séisme ou une
inondation j'insiste sur le fait que ces
résultats seront rendus publics sur le
fait aussi que les prescriptions
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire seront
systématiquement pris en compte au
niveau national comme au niveau
international la France continuera à
promouvoir les normes de sûreté les plus
exigean c'est de notre point de vue la
condition première d'acceptabilité du
nucléaire en France et d'ailleurs du
nucléaire partout je vous propose de
passer la parole à Éric Besson monsieur
le Président si vous l'acceptez et bien
vous me soulagez d'un travail vous
pensez effectivement que c'est une ruee
journée pour moi donc monsieur le
ministre merci Madame la
Ministre merci Messieurs les Présidents
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs natthalie
cosuscomorisé étant rapidement revenu
sur l'enchaînement et les causes de
l'accident sur lesquels reviendront
j'imagine beaucoup plus en détail le
président de l'ASN la présidente de
l'IRSN l'administrateur général du CEA
les industriels dont les président et
président deedf et et d'Areva je
voudrais moi
saluer votre invitation vous remercier
de cette audition qui contribue à
l'effort de transparence que nous devons
à nos concitoyens je crois que que cet
effort de transparence il est manifeste
depuis samedi date à laquelle Nathalie
kzuscoomorisé et moi-même nous avons
rassemblé tous les acteurs de la filière
nucléaire et rendu publ l'ensemble des
informations en notre possession depuis
l'ASN l'IRSN et le gouvernement
informment sans relâche nos concitoyens
et je veux le dire un peu solennellement
toute l'information dont nous disposons
nous la diffusion nous ne travestissons
aucune réalité l'audition que vous tenez
aujourd'hui en est je crois la meilleure
preuve nous voulons aussi assurer le
gouvernement japonais du soutien de la
France et de la communauté
internationale le Japon a demandé le 14
mars l'activation de la convention
internationale d'assistance en matière
de sûreté nucléaire l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique est
désormais compétente pour coordonner
l'assistance intern national aux efforts
japonais sur les sites nucléaires nous
avons donc demandé immédiatement à
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire de
préparer la contribution technique de la
France en liaison étroite avec les
différents ministères et avec bien
évidemment des exploitants et les
industriels je veux saluer l'effort des
industriels j'ai entendu ce qu'avait dit
Anne lvergon la présidente d'ARVA j'ai
entendu ce matin le PDG deedf Henri
progliot mobilisé des moyens robotiques
des des stocks de bord c'estàdire
l'élément chimique qui permet de stopper
une réaction nucléaire ainsi que ces
équipe j'ai compris qu'une importante
réunion se tient monsieur le Président à
l'ASN à 17h l'objectif est que la
proposition d'assistance de la France
soit à la hauteur de notre savoir-faire
dans le domaine
nucléaire nous entendons tous et nous
voulons tous que la France doit tirer
tous les enseignements de cette cat
je veux revenir sur le choix de notre
pays la France a fait effectivement le
choix depuis plus d'un demi-siècle de
l'énergie nucléaire ce choix je le dis à
un moment que je sais particulièrement
sensible ce choix me semble pertinent
pour quatre raisons principales
premièrement parce qu'il assure
partiellement l'indépendance énergétique
de notre pays ce qui dans ces temps
d'instabilité internationale ne doit pas
pas être négligé deuxièmement les prix
des autres énergies disponibles et en
particulier du pétrole augmentent et
resteront élevés en toute hypothèse
notre parc nucléaire permet aujourd'hui
aux Français de bénéficier d'une
électricité 40 % moins cher qu'ailleurs
en Europe ce parc nucléaire est l'un des
éléments de compétitivité de notre pays
trèmement l'énergie nucléaire est la
moins émettrice de gaz à effet de serre
et la limitation des gaz à effet de
serre doit être une priorité comme nous
l'avons affirmé lors du Grenel de
l'environnement qurièmement la France
dispose non seulement d'un parc de 58
réacteurs et d'un exploitant qui se
dispose de références en matière de
sûreté mais aussi de capacités
industrielles et de compétences
reconnues partout dans le monde mais ce
choix en faveur de l'énergie nucléaire à
une contrepartie indissociable une
exigence absolue en matière de sûreté
nucléaire la loi sur la transparence et
la sécurité nucléaire de 2006 a doté la
France d'une organisation et d'outils
puissant en matière de sûreté nucléaire
cette organisation s'appuie notamment
sur l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
autorité administrative indépendante et
dont il vient d'être dit à juste titre
que c'est un véritable entre guillemets
gendarme du nucléaire elle contrôle
cette autorité les sites nucléaires et
peut imposer des prescriptions aux
exploitants qui peuvent aller jusqu'à la
fermeture en cas de risque grave l'ASN
s'appuie également sur l'expertise
pointue de l'Institut de Radioprotection
et de srté nucléaire
l'IRSN ici présent également qui exerce
la surveillance de la radioprotection
sur notre territoire la France a fait de
la transparence un fondement de la
Sûreté Nucléaire le moindre incident ou
dysfonctionnement aussi minime soit-il
et si signalé automatiquement à l'ASN
l'ASN évalue et qualifie l'importance de
ces incidents et les rend public dans
des délais extrêmement court le
gouvernement a également mis en place en
application de la loi de 2006 le Haut
Comité pour la transparence et
l'information sur la sécurité nucléaire
présidé par Henri Revol ici présent un
organe collégial qui permet notamment
d'améliorer l'information auprès du
grand public notre système de sûreté et
d'information est ainsi robuste et
reconnu dans le monde entier pour son
excellence technique pour son
intransigence pour son indépendance et
pour sa transparence armé de ces outils
nous devons désormais faire toute la
lumière sur l'accident japonais et
surtout en tirer toutes les conséquences
sur notre propre parc comme l'a annoncé
le Premier ministre hier après-midi à
l'Assemblée nationale il sera procédé en
toute transparence à une revue complète
de sûreté de chaque cha réacteur au
regard des événements de type séisme ou
inondation et à la lumière du drame de
fushikuma de Fukushima pardon les
résultats en seront rendus publics et
les prescriptions de l'ASN seront
systématiquement prises en compte n
tireront toutes les renseignements tous
les enseignements de cette catastrophe
la revue portera notamment sur les
quatre points suivants d'abord le risque
sismique ensuite le risque d'inondation
le risque de rupture des moyens de
refroidiss et on a bien vu dans la
catastrophe actuelle que c'était le
maillon faible le point sensible les
outils qui permettent de faire face aux
situation extrême de fusion totale ou
partielle du cœur d'un réacteur comme le
récupérateur de corium que nous avons
prévu pour le Pr pour tirer les leçons
de cette catastrophe la France n'agira
pas seule évidemment elle souhaite
partager son exigence au niveau
international et entraîner la communauté
internationale vers plus de sûreté c'est
pourquoi la France apporte son plein
soutien à la démarche d'évaluation de la
sûreté des centrales engagées au niveau
européen c'est pourquoi également la
France intensifiera ses efforts pour
élever et harmoniser les normes de
sûreté au niveau européen et
international conformément aux
engagements pris lors de la conférence
sur le nucléaire de Paris en mars 2010
je conclus messieurs les président en
disant que l'association du public à nos
choix énergétiques est un facteur Essen
de notre démocratie le gouvernement
français écoutera avec attention les
propositions soumises pour améliorer
notre système énergétique le
gouvernement prendra aussi l'initiative
dans les prochaines semaines le
président de la République l'a dit voulu
annoncé de réunir l'ensemble des
ministres de l'économie et de l'énergie
du G20 pour examiner ensemble les
grandes questions relative à la
politique énergétique je vous
remercie merci merci monsieur le
ministre je vous signale que France 3 a
rejoint LCP et LCI pour retransmettre en
direct notre débat conformément à
l'habitude des commissions il sera donné
la parole au groupes politique pour 5
minutes parce qu'il faut laisser je vous
rappelle que les ministres vont nous
quitter vers 16h45 il faut laisser du
temps pour les réponses aux questions
que vous aurez posées ensuite nous
ouvrirons largement le débat à tous ceux
qui sont ici présents monsieur le
Président héros vous avez demandé le
premier la parole je vous la donne merci
monsieur le Président messieur mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je serai bref simplement
pour pour vous dire que les socialistes
ont demandé par la voix de Martin auri
un audit sur la sécurité de nos
centrales et la prolongation éventuelle
de leur durée de vie et hier et vous
venez de le confirmer Madame et Monsieur
le Ministre le Premier ministre a
répondu à cette demande positivement et
nous nous en félicitons alors c'est vrai
que cela doit conduire euh à toute
éventualité et en tout cas et cela doit
conduire à prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour assurer la
sûreté de toutes les
centrales même si on a dit que tout
avait déjà été fait et que tout était
sous contrôle mais les événements
tragiques du Japon nous montrent à
l'évidence que il faut sans cesse faire
monter le niveau d'exigence et donc au
regard de ce qui se passe et les
enseignements qu'on aura ensuite à tirer
il faut donc exclure au C N éventualité
y compris d'aller jusqu'à arrêter
l'activité de certaines centrales si
nécessaire il faudra avoir le courage de
prendre cette responsabilité je dis bien
si nécessaire donc faisons cet audit
mais la confiance est vous y avez fait
allusion suppose une totale transparence
et c'est pour ça je fais deux demandes
la première il m'a pas été répondu hier
par le Premier ministre alors que je lui
ai demandé c'est la de rendre publique
le rapport de François Roussely et qui
est actuellement classé secret
défense il n'est pas
sain que nucléaire rime avec secret et
qu'il faille attendre les
fuites dans la presse pour connaître le
sens des préconisations qui ont été
faites sur l'avenir de la filière
industrielle nucléaire française donc ça
c'est la première condition de la de la
confiance et la deuxième proposition que
je fais c'est que puisque les européens
se sont mis d'accord pour un audit de
l'ensemble du parc nucléaire de l'Union
européenne c'est que les expertises
puissent puisse être pluraliste et
croisé et pas seulement
française c'est une garantie je crois de
crédibilité et ça sera aussi le meilleur
moyen
d'avancer concrètement de façon
pragmatique pour l'adoption de normes
internationales parce qu'on voit bien
que cette question est désormais posée
avec actuité je ne développe pas
davantage les les les autres points je
pense que sur nous sommes là face à une
situation d'urgence nos compatriotes
attendent des décisions claires attendre
la transparence et et nous sommes là
pour que chacun puisse prendre ses
responsabilités voit le sens des
questions que je pose et des
préconisations que je fais je sais pas
j'ai l'impression que ça agite quelques
collègues de l'UMP mais ça ne
m'impressionne pas je crois que là les
questions sont suffisamment importantes
et graves pour qu'on puisse aller
au-delà des petites polémiques et donc
je vous pose ces questions précises et
j'attends des réponses précises merci
monsieur le Président héros j'aimerais
s'il vous plaît qu'il n'y ait pas de
conversation particulière à haute ou à
moyenne voix pendant que les uns et les
autres s'expriment je donne la parole
maintenant au représentant du groupe UMP
monsieur Loir pour 5 minutes le
président héros a tenu son temps donc je
vous invite à le suivre merci monsieur
le Président Madame le MIN monsieur le
ministre j'interviens en tant que
représentant du groupe UMP mais j'ai le
sentiment surtout après la séance que
nous avons vécu hier qui était tout à
fait exceptionnelle
que je peux m'exprimer au nom de
beaucoup au-delà d'éclévages politiques
pour d'abord redire notre émotion notre
compassion je pense également aux
techniciens japonais qui sont derrière
les instruments de contrôle qui lutent
avec beaucoup d'ardeur en prenant des
risques considérable nous pensons
également à eux je voudrais souligner
d'abord que il y a eu trois accidents
trois catastrophes nucléaires
frayadland Tchernobyl et
Fukushima il est important de distinguer
et les raisons et la nature et les
conséquences de ces trois catastrophes
j'y reviendrai dans quelques instants
alors trois questions se posent pour
l'opinion d'abord quelles sont les
retombées
exact des fuites radioactives constaté
au Japon il y a moins d'un an un volcan
islandais s'est promené à travers le
globe en tout cas sur une partie du
globe spontanément l'opin on se demande
si les mêmes vents ne peuvent pas
produire les mêmes effets et si
finalement malgré la distance qui nous
sépare du Japon nous sommes aussi à
l'abri qu'on le croit contre les
retombées
radioactives deè
question quelles sont les différences
entre les réacteurs japonais les
réacteurs français nous sommes un
certain nombre à bien connaître les
centrales nucléaires japonaises nous
sommes quelques-uns à les avoir visité
Fukushima en particulier d'autres nous
en avons visité
d'autres d'abord nous ne pouvions pas
imaginer qu'un tel accident pouvait se
produire au Japon tant nous avons
toujours été impressionnés par le niveau
de sûreté et la qualité des prestations
et des interventions des autorités
japonais et des ingénieurs
japonais de ce point de vue-là avec
tchernoby on mesurait qu'on pouvait
beaucoup mieux faire pour le Japon c'est
plus difficile alors notamment sur le
plan strictement technique je me
rappelle qu'au moment de tchernobile il
y avait eu un débat sur la double
enceinte de confinement qu'en est-il
exactement des réacteurs
japonais 3è question évidemment quelles
sont les garanties qu'on peut apporter à
l'opignon quelles sont les précautions
qu'il faut prendre dè aujourd'hui dans
les heures qui suivent les jours qui
viennent mais évidemment
demain ce Parlement peut s'honorer
d'avoir voté la loi de domicile sur la
transparence et d'avoir mis en place une
autorité de srté nucléaire qui est une
référence mondiale et je veux dire ici à
Monsieur lacostte combien nous
apprécions le travail qui est fait par
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire tout en
sachant que par moment on on pouvait
penser que le gendarme que vous êtes
était je ne dis pas excessif mais très
très exigeant pour notre industrie
nucléaire quelles sont les
préconisations que vous pouvez faire
enfin il y a au-delà de ces questions
qui sont posées par l'opinion deux
questions qui qui interpellent à la fois
les autorités et les
entreprises quelles sont d'abord les
conséquences de cette catastrophe sur le
développement du nucléaire dans le monde
il y a déjà quelques mois nous
commençons à prendre conscience que le
nucléaire est en train de se développer
qu'il est en train de repartir à travers
le monde il y a 200 réacteurs nucléaires
qui sont prévus d'ici à 2030 quels sont
les impacts de cette catastrophe et puis
une autre question nous avons été
frappés de voir qu'il y a dans l'accid
la catastrophe un accident spécifique
sur le combustible entreposé dans les
piscines alors la question est la
suivante dans un rapport qui a été
rappelé il y a un instant il y a me
semble-t-il une proposition qui consiste
à dire en réponse à ceux qui
s'inquiètent de savoir ce qu'il faut
faire des déchets nucléaires la réponse
c'est mettonsles dans les piscines
est-ce que c'est pas le moment de
reparler de la question du stockage des
déchets nucléaires de longue durée car
la solution qui est préconisée celle qui
est mise en œuvre au Japon a montré ses
limites merci monsieur le
Président merci mon cher collègue
d'avoir respecté votre temps de parole
je donne la parole maintenant pour le
groupe GDR à Monsieur Daniel Paul je
crois qu'il va partager son temps donc
ça fait minutes chacun ce sera très
rapide monsieur le Président ou les
Français à juste titre s'interrogent et
je l'ai rappelé hier dans la question
que j'ai posé au gouvernement à Monsieur
le Premier
Ministre l'entreprise japonaise et MO il
s'interroge d'une part parce qu'on sait
qu'une part de la pérennité du nucléaire
de l'acceptation du
nucléaire tient dans notre pays et
ailleurs tient au fait
pas que cette acceptation sociale de
cette source d'énergie de l' s'appuie
s'appuie
surabsence seul monsieur Paul a la
parole s'appuie sur l'absence monur Paul
a la parole merci les ministres vous
faites dégager vos voitures s'il vous
plaît non mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
le
sujet allez prenez une ben vous êtes ici
ça suffit ça va allez c'est pas le sujet
pour
allez c'est pas le sujet
asseyez-vous vous non c'est pas le sujet
c'est hors de hors
sujet asseyez-vous laissez parler
monsieur Paul monsieur Paul seul a la
parole c'est moi qui mène le débat c'est
pas
vousz ça n'a rien à
voir non non non non ça suffit ça suffit
monsieur le Président si vous me
permettez
s'il s'agit de la voiture de
naalieusorisé et moi-même les
conducteurs sont forcément dans les
voitures et il suffit que Monsieur grem
le demande ils vont bouger il y a pas
besoin de s'exciter pour ça bon revenons
au sujet monsieur Paul ne vous laissez
pas perturber monsieurésid par vre
collègue de groupe merci monsieur le
Président je disais donc que les
Français à juste titre s'interrogent on
sait qu'une part de la pérennité du
nucléaire dans notre pays et ailleurs
tient à l'acceptation sociale de cette
source d'énergie et à la confiance dans
un système où le taux de profit
n'impacte pas les règles de
sécurité or l'organisation du travail au
sein des centrales est un élément de cet
enjeu l'entreprise japonaise en cause
est une entreprise privée il me semble
même que c'est la première entreprise
privée au monde dans le secteur du
nucléaire elle s'est signalé déjà dans
le passé par un certain nombre de manque
aux règles de sécurité et elle a fait
l'objet de rappel à l'ordre à ce sujet
les députés communistes vous le savez
estiment que le secteur nucléaire doit
échapper totalement à la vision
courtermiste de la rentabilité
financière alors trois questions rapides
ne peut-on craindre que les règles de
fonctionnement des centrales y compris
en Europe où tous les exploitants sont
des sociétés anonymes soient impactés
par les objectifs de rentabilité et je
souhaiterais donc qu'au quatre objectifs
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
Madame et Monsieur le Ministre vous
ajoutiez la façon dont fonctionne dont
est organisé le fonctionnement à
l'intérieur des centrales je pense en
particulier à la prise en compte de la
maintenance dans nos centrales au
recours à des personnels comme ce que
l'on appelle les nomades du nucléaire et
puisque l'Europe est saisie ne
convient-il pas aussi de mettre sur la
table l'enjeu d'une maîtrise publique et
totale de la filière nucléaire et de
revoir l'obligation qui a été faite à
tous les opérateurs historique publique
d'ouvrir leur capital à des intérêts
privés merci Monsieur
Cochet merci monsieur le
Président mes propos vont peut-être être
assez contrastés par rapport aux
orateurs précédents et à ceux des
ministres la situation telle que je la
vois aussi bien que vous me semble
incontrôlable et
irréversible et c'est un changement
au-delà de quelques améliorations
techniques ou de quelqu audit dont on
parle aujourd'hui évidemment notre
solidarité est totale mais notre colère
est
immense le nucléaire et nous le disons
avec constance depuis 35 ans le plan de
Monsieur Mesmer est une industrie
dangereuse chère et inutile il faut donc
sortir du nucléaire en France et dans le
monde ceci est possible techniquement
financièrement et socialement en 25 ans
je n'ai pas le temps de vous donner les
détails je vois que d'ailleurs c'est mal
parti puisque rien qu'à cette audition
aujourd'hui il y a bien sûr et c'est
normal les ministres et les
administrations et entreprises
concernées mais il n'y a pas la société
civile c'est-à-dire par exemple des gens
indépendants tels que la crirade le GSI
Greenpeace ou les Amis de la Terre
et
silence monsieur cocher seul à la parole
et que par conséquent si audit il y a et
je m'en félicite j'espère que cet audit
sera de fond en comble et de bout en
bout et dans son ensemble et dans son
détail entièrement aussi associé avec la
présence des organisations telles que la
criade le GS Green Peace pour les Amis
de la Terre qui eux sont des gens qui
sont également des experts du nucléaire
depuis très
longtemps troisièmement troisièmement je
vous pose la question madame et monsieur
le ministre je souhaite comme d'ailleurs
quelquesuns de mes collègues
parlementaires qu'il a un débat sur le
nucléaire en France pas un grand débat
sur la politique énergétique mais sur le
nucléaire et que ce débat bien sûr soit
ensuite tranché par les citoyens assez
tôt à la fin du débat par un référendum
oui ou non nos concitoyens veulent-ils
sortir du nucléaire ou pas enfin je
relève et quelques questions aux
autorités du nucléaire et à vous-même en
tant que ministre est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour que les réacteurs de plus
d'une trentaine d'années je veux parler
de FA je veux parler de Graveline je
veux parler de buget de Tricastin et
d'autres soit le plusôt possible
c'est-à-dire maintenant fermé comme
d'ailleurs Madame Merkel qui n'est
pourtant pas une écologiste patenté le
propose en
Allemagne la moitié des pays de l'Union
européenne n'ont pas de nucléaire et ça
n'est pas les circonstances actuelles
qui vont les y inciter enfin je pose des
questions peut-être plus précisément aux
autorités du nucléaire est-ce que il y
aura
y compris à partir de l'accident et de
la catastrophe de Fukushima un nombre
d'incidents et un nombre d'anomalies qui
semble-t-il en France ont augmenté et
même multiplié par 2 depuis 10 ans c'est
l'autorité de sûreté du nucléaire qui
nous l'prend quand on parle de
transparence je veux donner qu'un seul
exemple que ceci est de la langue de
bois c'est que il y a même pas 2 ans à
cadarche euh a été masqué le fait que il
a fallu attendre le 6 octobre pour que
plusieurs dizaines de kilos de plutonium
qui était repéré depuis le mois de juin
et était dévoilé publiquement alors
quand on parle d'immédiateté de
transparence ça fait 35 ans que
j'entends ça et évidemment ça n'est pas
le cas ça n'est qu'un exemple il y en a
d'autres enfin je veux terminer quand
même par une question terminer Monsieur
Coch parce question minist comment
faalité entre les groupes comment se
fait-il que après la loi de 2006 cette
loi qui a décidé dans la loi un PR la
Commission nationale du débat public a
été saisie après la loi qui a décidé de
l'UP c'est-à-dire que même sur
l'opportunité de construire ou pas les
citoyens étaient désormais muets ceci
évidemment montre le poid du lobitaire
et les raisons pour lesquelles nous
avons de nous y opposer merci Monsieur
Cochet pour rester dans le temps des uns
et des
autres je consulte les ministres les
présidents des groupes
d'études du séjour pardon pour le groupe
Nouveau Centre d'abord merci monsieur le
Président de ne pas oublier les
centristes donc
euh nous voulons d'abord dire nous notre
euh vous étiez excentré par rapport à
moi notre solidarité notamment euh avec
la démarche qui a été proposée par le
Premier ministre hier à l'Assemblée
nationale donc d'abord une solidarité
avec le peuple japonais et ensuite la
proposition d'un audit qui sera fait
centrale par centrale sur le territoire
national nous pensons vraiment que ce
débat et le débat sur qui suivra l'audit
doit être fait en dehors de l'émotion et
nous plaidons effectivement pour que la
démocratie représentative joue tout son
rôle là nous pensons vraiment que c'est
pas un débat à confier à l'émotion et au
référendum alors je suis d'un avis
absolument contraire de celui qui a pu
exprimer Yve cocher là-dessus sur ce
débat national vous avez vous avez
monsieur le ministre posé un certain
nombre de critèr vous avez parlé du
risque sismique et effectivement on peut
se poser des questions quand on connaît
les les lignes de fracture sismique de
notre pays la vallée du rein les
Pyrénées la vallée du rô vous avez parlé
des inondations et et vous avez parlé de
la centrale de blayer je crois que c'est
natalieusin qui l'a fait est-ce que
l'âge des centrales sera un des critères
retenus c'est un un vrai débat par
rapport à encore une fois à l'usure de
de de fonction essentiell et derrière ce
débat sur l'âge je pense que nous
n'éviterons pas à la lumière d'un
événement de cette taille un débat sur
l'opportunité ou la remise en cause de
la prolongation de la durée de vie de
notre parc nucléaire cette prolongation
faisait on peut le dire consensus entre
nous à peu près quasi consensus si on
sort les vers je pense qu'à la hauteur
de cet événement il faut revenir sur
cette question et y revenir à fond donc
question comment comptez-vous organiser
le débat justement sur est-il encore
opportun de prolonger la durée de vie de
nos centrales nucléaires il nous semble
que c'est une question
fondamentale par rapport donc à nos 58
réacteurs dernier point qui nous tient à
cœur c'est le débat européen alors
effectivement quand on a un événement de
cette taille c'est à la fois bien sûr
beaucoup de danger mais c'est une
opportunité et l'opportunité elle est
majeure de pouvoir tirer vers le haut et
d'harmoniser les normes de sécurité
nucléaire sur l'ensemble des 27 pays du
de l'Union européenne et donc nous vous
posons une question claire quelle va
être la la politique que vous allez
mener au niveau du du sein du Conseil du
ministres européens et des chefs d'État
pour arriver une harmonisation par le
haut des normes de sécurité
européennne merci Monsieur Dionis du
Séjour compte tenu de l'heure je propose
que les ministres répondent puis as
après les présidents des groupes
d'études de l'énergie puis débat général
ouvert à tous les parlementaires vous en
êtes
d'accord oui non mais les experts ils
viendront après parce que les ministres
ils doivent partir donc s'il y a des
questions non non on perturbe pas le
débat les ministres
d'abord je je vais répondre à une partie
des question question et et proposer à
er de de répondre à à une autre
partie à l'attention de de Jean-Claude
Lenoir qui
relevait le phénomène de courant
atmosphérique qui avait eu à l'occasion
du volcan
oui ça c'est le retour de
Maxime
oui je pense que c'est important ouais
là on est dans les R
c'est quand même vous avez fini demandez
au chauffeur de déplacer les voitures et
puis taisez-vous ça doit pas être les
NES à mon avis
écz don le numéroimmatriculation on va
aller vite allez vite chercheer le
numéro allez madame la ministre vous
avez la
parole ça suffit ça
suffit c'est indigne c'est indigne du
déb question nous parlons ici de choses
sérieuses s'il vous plaît madame la
ministrevez la parole pense que la
question posé par Jean-Claude Lenoir à
son importance c'est la question de
savoir si par exemple en France
métropolitaine nous aurons des rejets
radioactifs du fait de l'accident de la
centrale de
Fukushima alors je vais être très
précis ça devent ridicule
non
mais mes chers collègues écoutez je
crois que c'est vra semblable monsieur
c'est un vrai semblable dans ce type de
débat c'est un vrai semblable c'est
indigne d'un parlementaire voilà moi je
veux le
dire par rapport à la situation que
connaît le Japon
aujourd'hui monsieur vous pourriez avoir
le minimum de
dessence pourit penser comme l'a dit
notre collègue tout à l'heure aux
techniciens aux ingénieurs japonais qui
risquent leur vie actuellement alors ne
nous cassez pas les pieds avec deux
voitures qui sont malgaré voilà et vous
laissez et laissez la place à au
directeur général du CEA s'il vous plaît
pas votre c'est la place de Monsieur
Bigot et je me permets de rappeler que
Monsieur grem n'est plus membre du Parti
communiste il est indépendant monsieur
gr n'est plus membre du Parti communiste
il fait la h
c'estr je condamne complètement son
Attitud je vous en
prie Monsieur Gret je vous en prie c'est
indécent vous êtes indécent monsieur
gremet vous êtes
indécent venir ici perturber voilà
petite interruption parce que vous venez
de le voir le député Maxime gremet est
rentré plusieurs fois dans la salle la
Martine pour protester apparemment
contre des voitures malgaré
le président de la séance Serge groire
l'a vivement rappelé à l'ordre voilà
apparemment l'incident est terminé et
nous repartons suivre les débats sur la
réunion sur la filière nucléaire on
repart tout de suite cellelà
Martine bon je vous prie de bien vouloir
accompagner monsieur Gremetz à sa place
mais pas ici ici
ce ici c'est la
place de l'administrateur général du CEA
monsieur
monsieur Gret nous
parlons voilà l'incident de séance en
fait avec Maxime gremet n'est toujours
pas terminé et on va tout de suite
rejoindre Fernand tavarz qui lui est
juste à côté de la salle la Martine où
vient de se produire cet incident de
séance alors Fernand est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus mais que
se passe-t-il bon écoutez j'ai rencontré
le député communiste Maxime Gremetz tout
à l'heure je me demandais ce qui se
passait parce que il est venu pousser
des cris et on avait pas compris très
bien pourquoi alors est-ce qu'il n'était
pas invité si tous les parlementaires
sont invités à venir discuter mais il
n'a pas supporté que devant l'entrée du
bâtiment réservé à l'Assemblée nationale
ici rue de l'Université et bien il y a
un certain nombre de voitures en
particulier des voitures ministériel qui
l'empêchait de venir jusqu'ici ce qui
paraît quand même un peu paradoxal je
pense qu'il a voulu faire un coup
d'éclat comme il sait le faire vous
savez en particulier Maxime Gremetz est
un petit peu coutumier de la du sujet
parce que euh les semaines dernières
vous savez qu'il fait partie de la
mission sur le Médiator alors cette
mission est composée d'un certain nombre
de parlementaires qui sont auditionnés
d'ailleurs ici salle la Martine et il
n'était pas content parce que dans cette
mission parlementaire il y'y avait que
des députés médecins et que lui n'était
pas médecin alors il a déjà fait des
coups d'éclat pour dire qu'il voulait
prendre la parole que lui il avait pris
du médiateur il a fait déjà un scandale
et dans cette affaire de voiture où tout
le monde dit bon bah d'accord on va
régler une fois pour toutes il est
ressorti il est à nouveau à l'entrée de
l'Assemblée nationale voir si les
voitures étaient parties il a constaté
que les voitures n'étaient pas parties
et il est redescendu faire son coup
d'éclat ce qui fait que les huissiers
sont dans tous leurs états ils ont
essayé de faire sortir le député mais
comme il est député c'est un élu de la
Nation il a le droit comme dit-il de
s'installer dans cette commission ce qu'
a fait évidemment ça mis en furie tout
le monde parce que il n'arrête pas de
parler et du coup les journalistes voyez
qui sont derrière moi et bien profitent
de cette suspension c'est un petit peu
la récréation mais franchement c'est
vrai sujetprement untit peu
catastropiquear c'est malvenu parce que
on a ici dans cette salle tous les
responsables de la circurité de la
sûreté nucléaire française et évidemment
on a également tous les responsables
mais fern du coup la séance est
interrompue que se passe-t-il on peut
savoir ce qui se passe Maxime gr
apparemment est toujours dans la salle
la Martine mais la séance est
interrompue c'est ça pour l'instant
parce que Monsieur gr n'arrête pas de
parler n'arrête pas de contester
veut rester à sa place et ce qu'on
essaie de faire parce que je l'entends
voyez la porte s'ouvre et se referme les
hissiers vont et viennent pour essayer
de le raisonner il n'entend rien il veut
parler il s'exprime il il estime que
c'est pas normal qu'on garde des
voitures on est complètement à côté de
la plaque et complètement à côté du
sujet il n'y a pas de fond et comme ça
fait des ordres parce que quand même
nous
som effectivement et nous sommes
effectivement en direct voilà Monsieur
gres qui par devant il vient passer
devant moi il est sorti il a accepté de
d'aller voir un ce qui se passe on va
lui faire constater et bien que
l'ensemble des voitures des ministres
merci est parti et que en tout état de
cause il peut revenir au calme et que
surtout cette audition peut reprendre
parce que voilà j'entends des
applaudissements ça veut dire que
l'ensemble des parlementaires voilà vont
interroger les invités on a entendu vous
l'avez vu tous les groupes d'abord
s'exprimer les ministres l'ont fait en
premier ensuite les ministres répondent
et on attend bien sûr maintenant des
explications plus précises et nous
sommes en direct en permanence sur la
chaîne parlementaire de l'Assemblée
nationale on sait tout on voit tout on
entend tout même les incidents
exactement merci beaucoup Fernand pour
toutes ces explications sur ce petit
incident de séance et donc la séance la
réunion sur la filière nucléaire vient
de reprendre salle l Martine et c'est la
ministre Nathalie cosuscooris la
ministre de l'écologie qui est en train
de parler on écoute tout de suite la
question ce n'est pas seulement la
distance à laquelle on est c'est aussi
le régime des vents et puis ça peut être
localement la
pluviométrie nos territoires d'outremer
par exemple les plus proches sont à 7000
km mais ils sont dans l'hémisphère sud
et le régime des vents les courant
atmosphériques on on se concentre
d'ordinaire à l'intérieur d'un
hémisphère ce qui fait je le redit que
si certains de nos territoires venaient
à être touchés les premiers territoires
les plus exposés ne sont pas forcément
ceux du Pacifique Sud mais peut-être
d'abord un territoire comme Saint-Pierre
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a lieu de
s'alarmer pour Saint-Pierre et miklon et
je le redis à ce stade aucune retombée
radioactive aussi lointaine ne ne ne
peut-être envisagé sur la base des
événements actuels encore une fois tout
ceci est en cours de modélisation et les
alertes nécessaires seront données s'il
y avait lieu maintenant si on va au bout
du scénario catastrophe que je décrivais
tout à l'heure il peut y avoir des
retombées dans une large partie de
l'hémisphère Nord y compris dans de
petite proportions en France
métropolitaine ce ne seront jamais des
choses des niveaux de retombée qui
poseraient un problème sanitaire elle
serait mesurée rendu publique en toute
transparence mais comme vous l'avez
soulevé à propos du volcan les les
cendres les particules peuvent être
porté assez loin et notamment assez loin
à l'intérieur d'un même hémisphère et
l'IRSN modélise tout ceci et et et et
tient nous tient informé et nous rendons
tout ceci public
en de manière tout à fait transparente
et immédiate sur la deuxième question
soulevée par Jean-Claude Lenoir la
différence entre les réacteurs japonais
et les réacteurs français je pense qu'il
faudra reposer cette question aux
experts dans la deuxième tranche celle
du débat avec expert néanmoins de ce que
je peux en dire les réacteurs japonais
enfin ce ces réacteurs japonais là sont
des réacteurs à eau bouillante nos
réacteurs français sont des Ré aeur à
haut pressurisé ça entraîne un certain
nombre de différences
techniques ça ça
ne ça ne veut pas dire non plus qu'ils
sont si différents que ça ce sont des
réacteurs cousins donc dans un réacteur
à eau bouillante il y a un circuit de
refroidissement unique dans un réacteur
à haut pressurisé il y a en quelque
sorte un double circuit ça certaines
différen pour les relâchements de vapeur
intentionnelles qui sont je le comprends
plus chargés dans un réacteur à haut
bouillant que dans un réacteur à haut
pressurisé au moins sur le deuxème
circuit ça n'entraîne pas tant de
différence que ça sur le circuit de
refroidissement il y a un circuit de
refroidissement il y a un besoin de
refroidissement pardon pas de circuit de
refroidissement du réacteur dans le
réacteur à haau Bouillante comme dans le
réacteur à haau pressurisé et dans les
deux cas s'il y a une défaillance du du
refroidissement ça pose un un très gros
problème sur la question de l'enceines
le seul réacteur qui est vraiment
différent essentiellement différent du
point de vue des enceintes c'est le 3e
génération c'est le Pr qui a double
enceinte avec une cuve très particulière
du point de vue de l'enceinte de
confinement un réacteur à eau bouillante
et un réacteur à eau pressurisée ne sont
pas fondamentalement différents je suis
sûr que ceci pourra être développé par
les experts par la suite enfin dernière
question de Jean-Claude Lenoir sur la
question du combustible stocké euh je
veux dire je comprend la question je ne
suis pas sûre qu'elle soit à l'espèce
pertinente pourquoi parce que le
combustible qui est dans les piscine de
du réacteur de Fukushima notamment dans
la piscine numéro 4 n'est pas un
combustible qui est stocké pour une
longue durée de vie en l'occurrence
c'est un cœur nucléaire qui a été
extrait du réacteur en novembre 2010 et
donc de toute façon si les Japonais
avaient ils ont un système assez proche
du N s'ils avaient un système avec du
stockage en grande profondeur s'ils
étaient plus avancés dans le type de
stockage que vous soulev ils auraient
néanmoins eu probablement ce cœur de
réacteur stocké dans la piscine numéro 4
du réaeur de Fukushima je comprends la
question que vous posez mais je pense
qu'en l'espèce ça n'est pas lié avec ce
qui se passe à à Fukushima je propose
que en accord avec lui Éric Besson
puisse répondre aux questions de Daniel
Paul je signale néanmoins juste un mot
sur le recours à ce que vous appelez les
les nomades à ce qu'on appelle en effet
les nomades c'est un point qui a été
soulevé par l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire ils ont
été dans les rapports de l'autorité de
seté nucléaire et un plan d'amélioration
a été demandé aux exploitants donc ce ce
problème est en est en est en cours de
de de traitement il a été relevé déjà
par
l'autorité sur les les questions
soulevées par Jean-Marc
hraud
pardon non non il croyait que vous
l'aviez oublié donc il était désespéré
non non pas du tout ENF je pardon je
prends dans dans l'ordre de de de de mes
notes euh
oui c'est toi qui répondus surtout je je
je réponds juste sur le deuxième point
l'expertise pluraliste est croisée éic
reviendra sur le rapport rousli sur
lequel je veis dire je suis moins
spécialisé crois que je ne sache pas
qu'il porte sur la sûreté
nucléaire ce qui est prévu pour le
diagnosticque l'audit centrale par
centrale de la sûreté des réacteurs en
France tel que l'a annoncé le Premier
ministre c'est que nous nous
coordonnions au niveau européen un
groupe à haut niveau ça a été annoncé au
niveau européen doit définir les
critères et les normes d'un tel audit
euh ce que les euh ce que certains ont
appelé à Bruxelles le stress test les
test de résistance ceci va être défini
au niveau européen et naturellement nous
nous nous prendrons en compte ces
propositions qui sont faites par les
Européens euh sont des propositions qui
permettront d'intégrer les retours
d'expérience les enseignements euh de de
la catastrophe de Fukushima et et et
donc nous aurons les mêmes les mêmes
normes en quelque sorte d' audit que les
Européens
euh la la façon de faire la procédure
euhh pour ces audite n'est pas encore
mise en place nous commençons juste à y
travailler naturellement il faudra que
l'expertise soi pluraliste sinon elle
n'aurait pas de valeur ajoutée euh par
rapport à à l'existant naturellement il
faudra qu'elle soit croisée
naturellement surtout il faudra qu'elle
soit la plus transparente possible il
s'agit de pouvoir rendre lisible
compréhensible aussi pour nos
concitoyens ce que sont le type de
catastrophe auquel nos réacteurs sont
aujourd'hui préparés et éventuellement
quelles sont les améliorations qu'on
doit qu'on souhaite qu'on peut y
apporter donc c'est bien l'esprit dans
lequel nous avons l'intention de faire
les choses euh concernant les questions
de Daniel Paul la société pardon di
cocher excusez-moi la société civile est
est déjà déjà présente en fait dans le
système à travers le Haut comité qui est
présidé par le sénateur Henri l Revol
c'est une des un des enjeux de ce Haut
Comité que de travailler l'association
de la société civile qui qui en effet
n'a pas forcément été historiquement le
point fort du secteur du nucléaire
l'audit quant à lui sera complètement
transparent donc dire chacun est associé
pour autant la société civile comme vous
dites n'est pas forcément experte et je
pense qu'il y aurait beaucoup de
contestations sur sur les sur les
experts que vous voudriez y
designer sur la question du débat sur le
nucléaire le président de la République
recevait ce lundi les ONG
environnementales du Grenel c'est une
réunion qui était prévue depuis
longtemps dans le cadre du processus
Grenel et naturellement on en est venu à
cette occasionl à parler d'énergie il a
redit son souhait qu'on puisse parler de
tout notamment parler d'énergie et s dit
ouvert à une forme de débat à définir
sur les énergies c'est un travail qui
est en cours de réflexion j'insiste sur
le fait que ça n'est pas dans dans cette
situation de crise de très grande
urgence y compris de grandes urgen
humanitaire maintenant radiologique au
Japon qu'on va pouvoir définir de la
meilleure manière en 24 heures ce que
vont pouvoir être les compour du débat
mais le principe d'un débat le principe
d'un débat le principe d'une réflexion
part AG le principe de d'une refondte
d'un consensus sur les questions
énergétiques il est acquis je crois pas
pour autant que le terme référendum soit
le mieux adapté d'autant plus que le
référendum que vous souhaitez ressemble
fortement à un processus en fait ou un
référendum électoral et il y en a un
l'année prochaine donc les choses ont
pas forcément besoin d'interférer euh
euh Éric vous répondra sur les réacteurs
de plus de 30 ans et sur l'augmentation
des anomalies euh dernière chose à
l'attention de Jean Dionis du
Séjour sur la question européenne quelle
est la politique que nous défendons au
Conseil des ministres
européens et au niveau international en
matière de sûreté nous cherchons à avoir
les normes les plus homogènes possibles
et et nous et nous défendons le niveau
maximum et de transparence et de normes
de sûreté donc toute initiative qui va
dans ce sens-là au niveau européen nous
convient et nous la soutenons sur la
question de la durée des centrales ceci
rejoint la question qui était posée par
ailleurs par r cocher et donc monsieur
le Président est-ce que Éric Besson mais
vous vous pouvez répondre mais j'ai
essayé quand même de synthétiser les
réponses parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'interrogations et beaucoup de
personnes
s'impatientent et et nous voudrions
pouvoir entendre les experts qui qui
sont là sur les questions précises qui
ont été posées je vais répondre très
vite pour la partie qui me concerne
Messieurs les Présidents d'abord à au
président hos dire effectivement que le
rapport rousli portait sur
l'organisation de la filière nucléaire
et notamment dans ses rapports à
l'export et non pas sur la sûreté la
seule partie qui a été l'essentiel du
rapport est disponible sauf une petite
partie qui a été classée de secret
défense c'est la seule partie qui n'est
pas disponible pour le reste
l'organisation de la filière en matière
de relation avec l'extérieur a été
redéfini lors d'un Conseil de politique
nucléaire qui s'est tenu il y a une
quinzaine de jours et qui désormais fait
foie à Jean-Claude Lenoir je veux redire
mais c'est un un grand spécialiste de de
ces questions Jean-Claude Lenoir que
c'est quand même un accident très
exceptionnel dans même dans sa
conception qui qui vient de de se
produire on ajoute un séisme de force
neuf et un tsunami dont la puissance et
la hauteur des vagues dépasse la hauteur
de la digue de 10 m qui avait été prévu
et qui paraissait déjà bien élevé il
semble les experts le confirmeront que
la vague qui est touché la centrale été
entre 15 et 17 m donc on pourrait
presque dire que c'est assez remarquable
finalement que la centrale elle-même est
tenu le double choc euh de du séisme
plus celui du tsunami en revanche on on
on comprend que le tsunami lui a affecté
les circuit de refroidissement primaire
et de secours et là il y a probablement
pour le retour d'expérience quelque
chose de très intéressant à à développer
sur les conséquences sur le nucléaire
dans le monde il est sans doute trop tôt
et et ça dépend en plus malheureusement
de de l'ampleur du drame qui se joue et
se noue actuellement peut-être que les
industriels pourront y répondre on voit
bien qu'un certain nombre de pays vont
probablement suspendre ou différer la
relance ou leur investissement dans le
nucléaire et que d'autres continueront
quand même pour ce qui concerne le
stockage de de longue durée il se trouve
que le mois prochain nous réunissons le
comité de haut niveau pour
l'accompagnement économique du
laboratoire de Bur et que je j'ai
programmé d'aller l'inspecter très
prochainement en tout cas le le chan
bien évidemment pour ce qui concerne la
question de de Daniel Paul sur les les
intérêts privés bon d'abord constatons
qu'à ce stade c'est une une question un
peu théorique puisque le seul
opérateur public l'exploitant EDF et est
public c'est une question qui pourrait
être d'actualité à l'avenir ah bah EDF
n'est pas publique sa sous-traitance ah
dans la sous-traitance ement
d'accord mais la la clé quand même c'est
que l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire elle
est publicique et c'est elle qui
détermine le cahier des charges et c'est
elle qui procède à toutes les les
vérifications
concernant les l'intervention de di
cocher je vais je vais très vite le le
débat sur le mix énergétique plus que
sur le nucléaire mais le débat sur le
mix énergétique il est constant il compr
au sein de de votre assemblée moi même
en tant que parlementaire j'avais
participé à des débats sur ce sujet je
ne crois pas qu'il n'est jamais cessé
alors il trouve un écho particulier
actuellement d'tacte mais il n'avait
jamais cessé pour ce qui concerne les
les anomalies le le président Lacoste
pourra répondre enfin on voit bien
comment comment ça se passe à partir du
moment où laasn fait le choix de la
transparence totale et que le moindre
incident aussi petit soit-il fait
l'objet d'une publicité il est pas tout
à fait anormal que le nombre d'incidents
puisse augmenter puisqu'ils sont de plus
en plus recensé pour ce qui concerne les
centrales de plus de 30 ans certains
dans la dans la salle se souviennent
quand même et il y a là des experts qui
pourront corriger ou amender si si je me
trompe mais les centrales nucléaires
françaises n'avaient pas été prévu pour
une durée de 30 ans elles avaient été
prévu pour une durée qui pouvait être
supérieure mais l'amortissement fin
avait été prévu pour 30 ans et à
l'aboutissement de ces 30 ans et ça a
été le cas pour la première centrale de
Tricastin l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
fait un examen complet une révision
complète pour pour parler simple et
ensuite puisqu'elle elle est d'autorité
indépendante le gouvernement se contente
de prendre acte de son avis c'est ce qui
s'est passé pour la première centrale
autorisée Tricastin le gouvernement par
un communiqué comme de Christine Lagarde
Natalie cosus comorisé et moi-même le 3
décembre dernier nous avons pris acte de
l'avis positif de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et nous avons donc pris acte
de la prolongation pour une durée de 10
ans de la centrale du Tricastin alors ça
va être échelonné pour fessanim le
l'ASN travail et la vie doit être
théoriquement rendu au au mois d'avril
notons quand même que la France est l'un
des rares pays au monde a accorder
l'autorisation de prolongation au cas
par cas en tenant compte de la situation
des centrales là où d'autrre prolonge de
façon collective et j'ai répondu je
crois à en même temps à à à la remarque
de Jean dioniste du du séjour je veux
simplement lui indiquer que dans ce que
l'ASN doit faire est tenu de de faire
lors de lorsqu'elle examine l'éventuelle
prolongation de la durée de vid des
centrales elle a l'obligation d'intégrer
tous les retours
d'expériur prés y compris
l'inondation qui sétait tenu en Gironde
à la centrale de Blayet et donc avec ce
qui vient de se passer au Japon y
compris l'éventuel retour d'expérience
de la catastrophe du Japon merci
Monsieur le Ministre est-ce qu'on peut
demander à l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire et son appui technique où ils
en sont ils nous font passer
régulièrement des information sur la
situation madame Busin est-ce qu'il y a
une cellule de crise qui a été mise à
l'IRSN comment qui la compose et comment
vous vous articulez avec l'Autorité de
sûreté
nucléaire en TR mots en tro mots la
cellule de crise a été gréée dès le
premier jour dès les premières heures du
séisme je dois souligner la réactivité
de l'Institut pour se mettre en ordre de
marche plus de 120 personnes ont été
mobilisées jour et nuit pour répondre
aux questions de nos concitoyens et vos
questions je dois rendre hommage au
travail du directeur général et des
équipes en terme de transparence et je
pense que vous nous attendez tous
là-dessus euh étant nommé président du
conseil d'administration venant de la
société civile ça a été la première
préoccupation que j'ai eu donc dès les
premières 24 heures j'ai demandé que
soit mise en ligne de façon continue les
mesures atmosphériques que donnent nos
balises sur le territoire national et
d'outres maire et que des points de
situation soient régulièrement publiés
sur le site internet de l'Institut pour
tout ce qui est du point de situation
technique je préfère laisser la parole à
Monsieur Repussard et l'interaction avec
l'autorité de sûeté nucléaire pour
l'instant je pense est parfaite nous
nous coordonnons en permanence nous
essayons de faire des points de
situation commun il n'y a vraiment aucun
dérapage
voilà m monsieur lacos puis monsieur
Repussard merci monsieur le Président je
dois d'abord noter comme l'ensemble des
l'intervenant précédent que le Japon vit
une véritable tragédie dont la crise
nucléaire n'est qu'une
composante je crois que c'est un point
tout à fait important le deuxème point
c'est que nousous efforçons de
rassembler ensemble des éléments
nécessaires dans cette situation tout à
fait tragique et il est clair que la
première préoccupation de nos
interlocuteurs japonais de gérer la
crise à laquelle ils ont à faire face et
que l'information versextérieur n'est
que une deuxième priorité j'ajoute assez
naturellement que les nos intereurs
japonais tendent à privilégier les
contacts avec leurs homologues ou les
autorités de sûreté qui ont une
connaissance spécifique des réacteurs à
eau bouillantees puisque c'est le modèle
de réacteur qui est utilisé sur le site
qui nous concerne principalement alors
j'en viens au site qui nous concerne
principalement c'est un site qui
comprend globalement directeur très
rapidement l'attention s'est focalisée
sur les six recteurs du nord de Fukushi
trois réacteurs étaient en
fonctionnement au moment où le
tremblement de terre et et le tsunami
sont intervenus trois réacteurs étaient
à l'arrêt d'emblé les trois réacteurs
qui étaient en fonctionnement ont été
arrêtés par arrêt automatique comme vous
l'avez
signalé et ils ont connu deux types de
difficultés ensuite difficulté
d'approvisionnement en eau d'une part et
d'autre part difficultés
d'approvisionnement électrique on est
entrer dans une séquence qui s'est
appliquée successivement au réacteur 1 3
puis 2 manque au début de de
d'endommagement des gaines de
combustible production de gaz volonté de
l'exploitant de
dépressuriser l'enceinte
et provocation je dirais
ou en conséquence explosion qui ont fait
sauter les superstructures du bâtiment
c'est déjà grave d'autant que la fusion
du combustible c'est poursuivi et
j'ajoute que sur lecteur numéro 2 est
survenu un endommagement de l'enceinte
de confinement qui elle est vraiment un
motif principal d'inquiétude ça veut
dire que sur le réacteur numéro 2 le
cœur est en communication avec
l'extérieur il y a un système de fuite
permanente comme si cela ne suffisait
pas sur le réacteur numéro 4 qui était
un réacteur qui était à l'arrêt au
moment des événements est survenu un
incident qui s'est transformé en
accident perte du refroidissement de la
piscine dans laquelle se trouvaient des
cœurs usés élévation de température et
le dénoiement semble se poursuivre et
donc si j'essaie de concentrer les
points sur lesquels notre attention est
particulièrement attirée et surtout
celle des Japonais mais il y a d'une
part le cœur du réacteur numéro 2 et y a
d'autre part le combustibisé du réacteur
numéro
4 la seule préoccupation que peuvent
avoir les les Japonais d'amener autant
d'eau qu'il est possible dans l'un et
l'autre cas les réacteurs qui ont
commencé à fondre les piscine avec le
combustible usé euh les moyens utilisés
sont les moyens en secours dont dispose
les Japonais nous avons de l'information
qui d'heure en heure indique que tel ou
tel moyen de fonctionnement fonctionne
ne fonctionne plus que tel van est
bloqué que tel camion qui amène de
l'eau à des difficultés d'accès nous
suivons ça d'heure en heure mais
l'ensemble de situations demeure
extrêmement grave et j'ajoute que ceci
nous conduit à une situation grave qui
au mieux va durer très longtemps et donc
nous espérons que au pire elle ne
conduise pas à une fusion encore plus
importante des combustible en cause
quelles sont les conséquences
radioactives ben d'une part il y a des
retombé radioactiv extrêmement forte
dans l'enceinte des installations qui
font que les opérateurs qui
interviennent sont exposés à des
conditions extrêmes Niel Buin avait
employé récemment le mot de condition
extrême d'intervention ce sont des
conditions extrême d'intervention elles
sont prévues dans les procédures en
France également dans des cas extrêmes
de ce genre l'exploitant serait amené à
à faire appel à des
volontaire il y a des règles en matière
de radioprotection qui sont établies
dans ce cas-là en système normal un
travailleur ne doit pas recevoir plus de
20000 C vertes par an de dose dans des
conditions intervention de ce genre il
peut recevoir jusqu'à 100000 s vertes
encore une fois volontaire et il y a un
système en France qui permet d'aller
jusqu'à 300000 s vertes pour une
intervention destiné à sauver des vie au
Japon ça se montre bien où on en est le
mise la Santé vient de décider de porter
de 100 2550 m C vertes la dose
l'équivalente donc condition
intervention extrême des personnes on a
parlé une cinquantaine d'entre elles il
est probable qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
beaucoup plus d'une cinquantaine de
personnes intervenant dans ces
conditions voilà on en est sur la
proximité la centrale et par ailleurs
les autorités japonaises ont pris deux
mesures qui nous paraissent tout à fait
raisonnables vu d'ici hein nous ne
sommes pas sur place et qui sont d'une
part une mesure d'évacuation dans un
rayon de 20 km tour à centrale ça nous
paraît raisonnable ça nous paraît fondé
et le Premier ministre annoncé récemment
une demande de mise à l'abri c'estàd de
confinement des gens dans un rayon de 20
à 30 km ça nous paraît encore une fois
raisonnable vu d'ici toute la
responsabilité repose sur l'autorité
japonaise mais ça nous paraît
raisonnable alors au-delà de ça bah il y
a plusieurs types de scénarios possibles
pour l'évolution de la situation une une
évolution dans laquelle peu à peu
l'exploitant japonais arriveraiit à
mettre suffisamment d'eau pour que
l'évolution en cours ne se poursuive pas
et puis une évolution beaucoup plus
négative alors ça nous conduit à classer
cet événement c'est au niveau 6 de
l'échelle Iness c'estàdire quelque part
entre l'accident de freemand survenu en
1979 pardon un demi un demi cœur de
réacteur fondu mais aucune conséquence
extérieure et chernoby explosion totale
du cœur quelqu parentre on est dans des
niveaux tellement peu habituels qu'il
faut faire attention à ce type de
comparaison alors la question qui se
pose ensuite est de savoir ques seront
les conséquences ultérieures au Japon en
retombéirsn a fait un certain nombre de
simulation dont il parlera et quelles
seront les conséquences en France tout
permet de penser que en France quel que
soit le scénario très vement il n aura
pas de conséquen d'impact sanitaire
notable mais vous voyez que nous sommes
en train d'évoquer les conséquences d'un
accident qui est tout à fait majeur un
accident de niveau 6 c'est majeur et
nous sommes en enc une fois dans un
déroulement sur lesquel si les choses
continuent tel qu si lesquatant arrivent
à remettre l'eau qu'il faut là où il
faut c'est stabiliser sinon ça devient
encore plus
grave monsieur Repussard
vous dans votre cellule vous faites de
la modilisation pour suivre l'évolution
de la radioactivité du nuage
radioactif monsieur le Président je
crois qu' un certain nombre des
parlementaires présents ici connaissent
l'IRSN et connaissent le Centre de Crise
de l'IRSN pour l'avoir visité je pense
que c'est un des équipements et une des
organisations qui est les plus solides
au monde et tous les entraînements que
nous faisons avec le avec EDF le CEA
d'un exercice à Reva d'un exercice
mensuel d'accident majeurs est un
entraînement euh qui est extrêmement
utile et les scénarios accidentels dont
on nous dit parfois que nous exagérons
quand nous les composons et que nous les
proposons aux exploitants et aux préfets
et bien nous voyons là dans la réalité
d'aujourd'hui que ces scénarios sont
malheureusement des choses
réalistes notre notre cellule notre
Centre de Crise donc comporte trois
trois cellules une cellule qui s'occupe
de la sûreté des réacteurs donc qui
observe la situation avec les éléments
dont nous disposons à travers le service
nucléaire de l'ambassade de France à
Tokyo avec lesquel nous travaillons en
étroite liaison et pour fournir les
informations sur lesquelles je ne
reviens pas donc à l'ASN qui qui les a
bien retranscrites je voudrais souligner
cependant que nous travaillons en
étroite liaison également avec les
États-Unis et avec l'Allemagne puisque
nous n'avons pas cette technologie des
réacteurs bouillants donc nous ne
disposions pas des plans des choses
comme ça mais la
collaboration avec nos amis américains
et allemands a été parfaite et
extrêmement intense malgré les décalages
horaires et c'est ainsi que nous pouvons
disposer d'un certain nombre
d'informations précieuses notamment sur
la modélisation c'est-à-dire la la la
représentation de ce que peut-être la
quantité de activité susceptible
d''échapper des enceintes
endommagées pour finir sur les réacteurs
euh c'est vrai que ces réacteurs sont
différents des nôtres mais
euh le scénario lui-même d'un d'une
perte de refroidissement est bien connu
et il n'est pas si différent en revanche
je voudrais souligner une différence que
qui jusqu'à présent n'a jamais été mise
en valeur au bénéfice des installations
françaises je ne parle pas pas de leur
protection contre les séisme ou contre
le l'inondation mais je parle d'une
spécificité qui à l'origine lors de la
conception a été une exigence de
l'ancêtre de l'IRSN l'Institut de
protection de sûrté nucléaire du
Commissariat à l'énergie atomique qui au
moment de la conception des centrale
française et ceci était une innovation
par rapport aux technologies américaines
importée a exigé que soit installée une
en ultime secours une turbine qui
fonctionne avec la vapeur produite par
le cœur nucléaire et ainsi nos réacteurs
français sont capables de faire
fonctionner des circuits de
refroidissement d'eau sans aucun apport
d'électricité sans diesel alors bien
entendu c'est un ultime secours mais si
cette ressource là avait été en place au
Japon et bien peut-être qu'il n'en
serait pas là donc je crois qu'il y a
des
différences de de conception peut-être à
la marge et c'est vrai que le sujet de
notre point de vue le sujet central
n'est pas tant le la résistance au
séisme ou auudessus ami parce que des
événements extraordinaires peuvent
toujours arriver on on l'a vu lors de
l'accident du BI de enfin l'accident
lors de la tempête du blayer par exemple
mais ce qui compte c'est la défense en
profondeur des installations et la
capacité à restaurer rapidement
c'est-à-dire en moins de 24 heures des
moyens de refroidissement des circuits
et c'est ça qu'il faudra comprendre au
Japon pourquoi malgré effectivement le
fait que le Japon soit un grand pays
nucléaire pourquoi ces ces défaillances
se sont
produites sur pour l'avenir donc le
gouvernement français a demandé à l'IRSN
d'élaborer des projets de recommandation
de
futures normes
internationales pour les réacteurs de
génération 3 nous avons nos règles pr
mais es ne sont pas suffisantes pour
couvrir l'ensemble de la gamme des
réacteurs génération 3 et nous nous
sommes attelés à ce travail important et
je voulais souligner que nous avons
fondé dans cette perspective européenne
donc qu'une association des IRSN
européens que nous travaillons la main
dans la main avec nos nos amis
américains et japonais le l'homologue
japonais de l'IRSN est membre de ce club
européen des experts de sûreté nucléaire
et notre opinion ferme est que la la
recherche ensemble le développement la
le partage par les experts d'une culture
partagée à travers des technologies
finalement qui se ressemble entre les
différents pays et le meilleur moyen de
d'aider à l'harmonisation qui aura une
étape réglementaire et au-dessus une
étape
politique maintenant je voulais dire
quelques mots sur les conséquences de
cet accident dramatique qui est en train
de se produire au Japon c'est-à-dire le
la diffusion du panache radioactif qui
actuellement s'étend sur une de manière
relativement concentrée sur une zone de
quelques dizaines de kilomètres autour
du site en fonction de la fluctuation
des vents qui globalement vont vers le
la l'océan Pacifique mais pas toujours à
cause de de la de la météorologie
côtière euh cette cette ce panache euh
finira par atteindre une dans les
prochains jours une une zone de
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres mais
nos calculs montrent que par exemple à
Tokyo où vivent encore 2000 français euh
et 35000 35 millions de Japonais et bien
le la la dosimétrie restera euh quoi
qu'il arrive sans conséquences
sanitaires visible on trouvera des des
rayonnements ionisants on trouvera des
particules radioactive mais les
conséquences dosimétriques seront à des
niveaux très très en dessous de ceux qui
justifierit par exemple l'administration
de comprimé diode donc ça il faut bien
comprendre cela il y aura une zone
fortement contaminée de l'ordre de 50 60
km autour du site donc il y aura la
gestion des territoires contaminés
mais dans à des distances plus grandes
même au Japon les conséquences seront
mesurables bien entendu mais n'auront
pas de conséquences dramatique et sur le
reste de la planète on a fait allusion
au volcans tout à l'heure ou aux
incendies de forêt en Russie ou à
l'accident de Tchernobyl et bien c'est
vrai que ces particules radioactives
seront
détectées sur toute la planète
progressivement surtout dans
l'hémisphère Nord parce que la
métrologie des rayonnements indisant est
si puissante qu'on peut détecter des
quantités extrêmement faibles donc sans
sans nocivité évidemment c'est une
pollution c'est une pollution de la
planète dont elle se serait sans doute
bien passé mais s'il faut articuler une
comparaison avec quelque chose je
voudrais vous ramener aux essais
atmosphériques des armes nucléaires dans
les années 50 et 60 et à l'époque et
nous allons mettre en ligne des cartes
historiques enfin des représentants
historiques des quantités de césium
radioactifs qui ont été àépérés à
l'époque et dont nous venions à peine de
nous affranchir maintenant puisque le
sésium a une demi-vie de so de 30 ans et
donc nous commencions à voir la fin de
la présence sur notre planète
des puisquil reste est enterré assez
profond dans les sols donc du césium des
essais nucléaires l'accident de thernoby
en a remé une couche nous allons en
avoir une nouvelle couche mais ces
couches-là sont inférieures sont sont un
ordre de grandeur inférieur à ce que
nous avons vécu dans les années 60 sans
que la sans qu'à l'époque ceci soulève
peut-être à tort d'ailleurs des une
émotion considérable parmi une société
qui qu'on avait pas informé tout
simplement
voilà donc il faut avoir en tête ces
grands ces grands ordres de grandeur de
telle sorte que nos concitoyens ne soi
pas
inutilement alarmé alors ceci étant
expliqué ne suffit pas nous avons et ça
fait partie de nos missions donc
monsieur le Président vous le rappeliez
mission de surveillance de la
radioprotection dans notre pays donc
nous avons mis en place plusieurs
dispositifs il y a les les balises dont
parlait madame Buzin qui sont des
systèmes automatiques de détection de
rayonnement gamma nous avons avons un
réseau qui s'appelle opéa de
surveillance des aérosols radioactifs
qui permettent de mesurer également
l'existence de particules qui ne sont
pas à rayonnement gamma mais qui peuvent
être tout aussi toxiques et nous avons
mis en place avec Aéroport de Paris
l'ambassade de France à Tokyo où nous
avons dépêché un expert en
radioprotection et avec Aéroport de
Paris donc Air France pardon un un
dispositif de surveillance et de et de
contrôle de la noncamin nation des
équipages d'Air France qui volent c'est
moins héroïque que les les exploitants
de la centrale mais enfin il faudra
qu'ils aillent au Japon avec leurs
avions les avions nous allons contrôler
leur contamination nous contrôlerons la
contamination des équipages ceci a
commencé avec des résultats négatifs
pour le moment sur les équipages
d'Air-France et nous contrôlerons
également les passagers qui seront par
qui auront été dans des régions
peut-être plus exposées ou qui auront
d'après eux-même pris des risques le
plus important voilà donc ce dispositif
de contrôle les résultats globaux on
sert rendus public les résultats
individuels relèvent du évidemment du
secret médical mais je peux vous assurer
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
Parlement que l'IRSN est entièrement
mobilisé sur ces sur ces questions et
que nous ne faillirons pas notre mission
au service de la transparence au service
du public et des autres pays puisque
laiaa et l'OMS dans l'IRSN les centre
référent de l'OMS c'est un privilège que
peu d'organismes au monde ont et bien le
l'OMS et laiaa nous demandent leur aide
pour évidemment ensuite aider les aider
à coordonner l'aide internationale qui
sera fourni au Japon à la demande de ce
pays je vous remercie merci Monsieur le
Directeur général je remercie d'ailleurs
l'IRSN comme laasn de nous tenir informé
régulièrement de l'évolution de la
situation vous avez parlé à ia on n pas
la Ia mais on a laen est-ce que Louis
sechevari en quelques mots vous pouvez
dire ce que fait la coopération
internationale pour le Japon en dehors
de recueillir les informations et merci
monsieur le Président merci pour
m'inviter à être ici aujourd'hui je veux
dire que la première chose à considérer
qui a été dit c'est qu'il faut voir le
contexte global d' pays qui a été
débasté pour des événements naturels
d'un proportion totalement inespéré et
c'est n'est pas aidé à la crise bien sûr
mais la situation
a
sitve et
nousp
dans tech par que
sont qui été mentionné la première chose
que je vais dire c'est que la présence
internationale de la France dans tous
les débats sur la seté nucléaire c'est à
les plus haut niveau il y a de pays qui
sont les plus haut niveau de coopération
internationale qui sont les États-Unis
et la France personalement André
lacostousard Bernard big participe
directement dans cette organisation
internationale quel personalement quelqu
group de traba mais plus important que
ça c'est que beaucoup de des des gens
techniques des experts de cette
organisation participe directement dans
tout le groupe de travail j'insiste que
les États-Unis et la France sont le deux
pays que participe dans tous les groupes
de travail qui débat la sé et la
protection
radiologique avec une participation
active le Japon participe beaucoup mais
je dire que son participation est un
petit peu différente en relation avec
l'activité de exp dans gr est-ce que le
Japon vous a demandé d'apporter une aide
technique à vous-même ou à la IEA ou
bien est-ce que vous êtes simplement
dans le fait de recueillir les
informationsarriver à cette à cette ch
que c'est le rôle des organisation
international il a in convonvention
d'assistante à des pays qui ont des
problèmes que c'est Aven et le Japon on
demandé desassist mais je que su un
petit exceptique de la capacité de la
organisationes internationales de donner
dans une situation de crise une in
effective que ninterfè pas dans la
situation locale je pense que sont les
grand les grands pays nucléairire d'une
manière bilatérale qui ont la capacité
d'envoyer les experts qui ont
l'expérience direct dans ce type
d'installation en ce type de situation
je pense que les États-Unis a réactionné
déjà et envoyé des gens son expert dans
les racteur de en ébolition la France je
pense que peut apporter une a très
importante dans aspect de la protection
radiologique en quelques autres aspects
additionnel de point de de l'Ance nous
sommance relativement petite et nous
avons une une rôle important nous somm à
la communication il a une demande dans
tous les pays de monde de qu'est-ce qui
passe de comparation entre les
accidentes comm th Island ternobil dans
ces cas aussi les aspectes de la
protection radiologique qu'est-ce qui va
passer dans le futur et nous participons
dans cette domaine mais le plus
importante pour nous qui a commencé déjà
c'est l'analyse technique de les
conditions qui en fait arriver à cette
situation beaucoup des aspectes été
mentionnés ici il y a des choses qui se
connaî aujourd'hui mais une connaissance
à profondeur va apprendre beaucoup de
temp et c'est important il y a des
mention sur la technologie concrète la
technologie concrète de évolution n'est
pas à l'origine de l'accident que
l'origine sont des vantes extérieur mais
peut-être que nous pouvons arriver à à
le point qu'il y a quelques
caractéristiques qui n' pas aidé dans le
processus de développement de
l'accidente il y a des aspects comme l'â
de la centrale à priori il y a des des
centrales de des qui ont été construit
dans des moments différents avec
technologie un petit peu différent il
paraît que pas mais peut-être queà la
fin C pe arriver à penser que quelques
réacteurs de quelques temp ne sont pas
si bien préparés pour des situations
comme cette il y a des aspects qui ont
été dit ici bien sûr que c'est peut
penser que une comme c'est dit séisme ou
une tsunami de cette dimension ne peut
pas passer mais c'est pensée c'est étit
la la la pensée à les Japon avant en
fait on était surpris pour la taille de
cette de cet événement il faut réviser
aussi la localisation de La central et
tous les aspects de catastrophes naturel
que peut affecter peut-être avec une
critur plus strict que dans le passé
parce que la réalité a démonstré que C
peut passer mais il y a beaucoup des
aspects que que il faut d' avoir
beaucoup plus des informations pour
arriver à une situation de améliorer
d'une manière déterminante la surité de
le réacteur mais pour le moment je pense
que que c a commencé déjà ne se pas d'e
manière internationale tous les autor
autorités de régulation de l en commencé
il a une révision spécifique de chaque
central pour s'assurer que le que se
connaît de l'accident de
Fukushima N a une impact direct dans ce
type de central et j'espère que dans les
prochains mois nous serons capables d'
arriver à une à une évaluation globale
comme ça fait dans les passé avec th
Island et chernoby que nous somm été
très actives arrivé à une très bon
connaissance de de cette situation je
pense que c'est notre apportation
principale et pour le moment et nous
pensons que c'est un impact dans le
futur bien sûr mais il aura des temp
pour pour voir qu'est-ce que cet impact
une de la caractéristiques de le
nucléaire et que tout développement des
nouveaux projets prend beaucoup des
années il y a des temps pour passer les
conditions de sûreté de les nouveau
réacteur merci monsieur chevari je crois
que nous allons pouvoir ouvrir le débat
euh général à moins que Henri Revol nous
dise un mot sur le président du Haut
Conseil où est-ce que vous en êtes annel
Vergon annel Vergon Henri
progliot quel est l'état de vos
réflexion est-ce que vous avez des
contacts avec Tepco
oui monsieur le Président d'abord je
voudrais m'associé aux paroles de
solidarité qui ont été prononcé
vis-à-vis du peuple japonais en général
et des Japonais qui sont sur les sites
en particulier dont le courage et et le
sangfroid non non dégal que la
détermination à lutter contre cette
catastrophe sur
le sur le sur les coopération que nous
que nous avons avec des opérateurs
internationaux quel qu'ils soit au
travers notamment de
l'Association des opérateurs nucléaires
internationaux que nous présidons
d'ailleurs qui s'appelle Wano ainsi que
au travers de la coopération quotidienne
que nous avons vis-à-vis des l'autorité
de seté d'une part et d'autre part on
peut dire
que évidemment nous
nous
informons en temps réel évidemment
minute par minute de l'évolution de la
situation don dont la description a été
faite avec
précision par le président de la
SN nous avons une coopération avec Tepco
l'opérateur japonais nous nous sommes
évidemment préoccupé de lui offrir toute
assistance nécessaire pour que à tout
moment nous puissions dans le
respect de bien sûr ses priorités lui
porter
assistance je vous confirme que nous
avons mobilisé des équipements
spécialisés lourds et adaptés à la
situation que nous le faisons en
coopération et en étroite
coordination avec l'IRSN et au travers
notamment du G que nous avons avec les
industriels français notamment à Riva et
le CEA au travers d'un GIE intra qui
nous permet de mobiliser tout toutes nos
toute notre aide
elle est immédiatement disponible nous
l'avons communiqué à nos collègues
japonais qui jusqu'ici n'y ont pas fait
appel mais qui apparemment cet
après-midi ont réagi positivement et je
pense que ça va donner lieu à une mise
en œuvre très
rapide voilà ce que je pouvais dire à ce
stade un Moot simplement euh des
opérations que nous menons évidemment en
France mais aussi dans d'autres pays
comme la Grande-Bretagne au service de
de la mission de service public qui nous
a été confié et notamment dans le
domaine nucléaire c'est vrai que la
sûreté est une obsession du quotidien
notre culture d'entreprise a été très
fortement marqué par cette
dimension nous y consacrons énormément
de moyens qui s'agisse de moyens humain
et
financier nous
consacrons l'amélioration la maintenance
aux grands entretiens des central ne
serait-ce que sur le territoire français
plus de 2 milliards d'euros par an et
nous avons évidemment euh euh la
l'ambition de continuer à investir
massivement de manière à continuer non
seulement à bien entretenir mais
également à améliorer
systématiquement l'efficacité la sûreté
de nos centrales et nous sommes
totalement déterminés à continuer dans
cette
perspective ce qui fait que lorsque
l'âge de la centrale est évoqué
évidemment une centrale
aujourd'hui une centrale même si elle a
10 20 ou 30 ans puisque que la
construction des centrales s'est étalée
pour ce qui concerne le territoire
français entre
1978 et
1999 elles sont de d'â différents mais
pour autant les notions de sûreté ont
été évidemment réactualisées et les
investissements ont été fait de manière
à ce que toutes les centrales disposent
du même de la même garantie de la même
sûreté par ailleurs nous tirons profit
de notre retour d'expérience nous avons
le plus grand retour d'expérience au
monde en matière de nucléaire puisque
nous avons 1500 anné réacteur de retour
d'expérience et nous adaptons et nous
adoptons une attitude systématique qui
consiste à nourrir notre retour
d'expérience de toutes les informations
à la fois du parc que nous gérons mais
également des opérations internationales
ce qui fait que nous avons déjà
améliorer le niveau de sûreté de nos
centrales au fur et à mesure en fonction
des retours d'expérience des accidents
qui ont été identifié bien sûr dans le
monde et notamment des plus graves que
sont tchernoby et
somaland euh nous avons tenu compte dans
la conception la réisation des centrales
euh de toutes les caractéristiques des
sites qui sont concernés
notamment nous avons en matière de
d'effet sismique tenu compte de deux
fois la plus grave intensité seismique
des 1000 dernières années dans la
conception et la réalisation des
centrales nous avons évidemment aussi
tenu compte de tous les éléments de
catastrophes naturelles inondation et
autres catastrophes naturelles qui se
sont produites dans le monde de manière
à adapter nos centrales et en anticipant
des conditions encore plus graves que
celles-là rien n'est jamais suffisant en
matière de sûreté et encore une fois en
coopération étroite avec les organismes
de sûreté qui sont ici présents nous
continuerons à adapter et anticiper euh
les conditions de sûrté de manière à
faire en sorte de garantir à nos
concitoyens et à tous ceux qui nous font
confiance les plus normes de sécurité
les plus ambitieuses et les plus
exigeantes au monde voilà monsieur le
Président ce que je voulais vous dire en
deux mots merci monsieur le Président
Madame l'auvergan vous êtes en contact
avec le Japon vos collègues euh
Messieurs les Présidents mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et députés
mesdames Messieurs chers collègues oui
bien sûr Tepco comme les autres
électriciens nucléaires sont nos clients
alors non pas dans le domaine des
réacteurs puisque les réacteurs ont été
construits à la fois par sur du design
américain avec des makers japonais mais
sur l'ensemble des autres sujets du
nucléaire ce qui nous amène
effectivement à avoir des relations très
suivi avec eux et vous le savez nous
avons une relation plus particulière sur
un centre de sujet avec
Mitsubishi alors je voudrais d'ailleurs
à ce titre redire ce qui a été dit mais
on ne le dira jamais assez toute notre
compassion vis-à-vis de tous ceux que
nous connaissons de tout ce que nous
connaissons pas au Japon et qui vivent
aujourd'hui un un véritable calvaire
direct ou
direct je crois que effectivement le
courage dont ils font preuve
collectivement et et le sansfroid
collectif de la population est
absolument admirable tant vis-à-vis du
tremblement de terre du tsunami que de
la menace nucléaire aujourd'hui qu'ils
vivent alors aujourd'hui si on analyse
la situation je ne reviendrai pas on
adhère totalement à l'analyse technique
qui a été fait euh s'il n'y avait qu'un
réacteur en défaillance effectivement la
situation serait facilement gérable le
problème c'est que nous sommes sur un
site où il y en a un certain nombre avec
unombre de de combustible donc c'est à
la fois le cumul et les circonstances
exceptionnel c'est-à-dire que il y a
plus d'alimentation électrique
normale je crois qu'il faut imaginer une
sorte de mangrauve entre la centrale et
et la mer on est dans la boue on est
dans les débris on n'est absolument pas
dans une situation normale
d'intervention où effectivement le Japon
que nous connaissons et que nous
connaissons tous interviendrait sans
aucune espèce de difficulté donc de tout
ces éléments bien effectivement nous
sommes dans une catastrophe alors je ne
vais pas revenir sur les événements mais
je voudrais seulement partager avec vous
notre analyse technique alors nous
connaissons effectivement les réacteurs
à eau bouillantes non pas notre
expérience française puisque la
technologie choisie en France est celle
de l'eau pressurisée mais de nos
développements à la fois en Allemagne
aux États-Unis où ce sont des réacteurs
à eau bouillante qui sont
utilisés bon les combustibles ne sont
plus refroidis et les centrales sont
arrêté c'est ce qui fait l'énorme
différence avec Chernobyl mais bien
évidemment si les combustibles ne sont
pas refroidis autant ceux qui sont dans
les cuves que ceux qui sont dans les
piscines la situation devient
extrêmement difficile donc la la la
situation nécessite aujourd'hui une
action urgente c'est nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans l'urgence
absolue et je crois que là-dessus il
faut être pratique donc la côté pratique
et l'analyse que nous en faisons c'est
qu'il faut essayer de trouver tous les
moyens pratique pour amener de l'eau euh
pour refroidir les centrales et les
piscines alors comment se fait
l'alimentation en eau on a vu la la
l'essai qui a été fait avec des
hélicoptères bon les hélicoptères sont
en vol stationnaire peuvent embarquer
qu'une quantité limitée d'eau les
hélicoptères ne paraissent pas de
d'Illes ça n'a pas marché ne paraissent
pas la la bonne solution donc notre
analyse c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut
environ 100 m³ d'eau euh par heure pour
l'ensemble du site et et alors c'est
tout à fait à la mesure de moyen
d'urgence si vous prenez par
exemple ce qui est utilisé pour éteindre
des incendies d'avion c'est-à-dire des
camions incendies ça débite 6 m³ par
minut et ça permet c'est des lances qui
permettent d'intervenir entre 50 et 80 m
ce qui est tout à fait dans la logique
de distanciation des problématiques de
radioactivité alors nous avons bien sûr
pensé aussi fondamentalement première
pensée était au canadaè français on a
regardé il faudrait 96 heur pour les
leur faire rejoindre la zone or nous ne
sommes pas je crois à sur une des time
limit qui sont de 96 he donc les camions
de pompiers 10 faunes qu'on utilise sur
les aéroports en France ils ont d'autres
noms dans d'autres pays nous paraissent
par contre beaucoup plus la réponse il y
a des bateaux pompes aussi qui existent
qui ont les mêmes capacités euh mais
alors là ce qu'on ignore totalement
c'est la distance qui existe à la mer
c'est-à-dire euh les marécages qui
peuvent exister cette espèce de zone
boueuse qui peut exister entre les deux
les tirants d'ailleurs des bateaux dans
ce domaine excusez-moi je vais couper ce
téléphone
importun c'est ma fille qui chante ça
c'est le côté euh c'est une sonnerie
téléphone plus sympathique euh les
bateau pompes ont un tir en d'eau
d'environ 2 m donc il y a un problème
technique alors ce que nous ce que nous
venons d'apprendre c'est
qu'effectivement il y avait un certain
nombre de de camions de pompiers qui
arrivaient des
États-Unis bon je crois qu'on a des
capacités en France là aussi je pense
qu'il y a des choses à faire très
vite dans un certain nombre de pays pour
pouvoir mobiliser avec les bons tuyaux
et les bonnes alimentations électriques
les capacité pour effectivement
stabiliser la température je pense que
c'est notre urgence internationale euh
collective
euh là-dessus donc je je me permets de
je me permets de partager avec vous
c'est notre analyse technique
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il est important
euh qu'on puisse la partager alors ces
ces ces capacités international euh bien
évidemment euh vous le savez elles sont
déjà mobilisées sur le séisme lui-même
puisque nous avons beaucoup
d'intervenants euh qui sont là euh je
dirais sur la sécurité civile euh il n'y
a pas eu de demande côté japonais à part
des demandes très spécifiques qui nous
ont été faites et auxquelles nous
répondons euh en liaison avec avec EDF
sur des des sujets très spécifiques et
nous avons un avion qui est prêt à
partir effectivement euh si nous en
obtenons les autorisations de de survol
des différents pays euh pour mais ça
c'est on est dans les moyens palliatifs
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on puisse
aussi intervenir dans les moyens puratif
tout de suite donc les jours qui
viennent sont bien sûr déterminants et
le plus vite possible sera le mieux je
crois qu'il faut passer à une autre
échelle dans la la façon d'amener de
l'eau et là-dessus donc une solution
massive à la crise est absolument
nécessaire bon pour ce qui les
collaborateurs d'AREVA nous en avons une
centaine au Japon nous avons 15
expatriés nous avions 18 personnes sur
le site les 18 personnes qui sont sur le
site qui sont des Allemands et des
Américains du fait des technologies ont
été rapatriés tout de suite et
l'ensemble des familles a été déplacé
temporairement vers le sud de l'archipel
tous les collaborateurs nécessaires à
Tokyo sont bien sûr à Tokyo euh nous
rappelons aussi qu'il y a 44 réacteurs
nucléaires en fonctionnement aujourd'hui
au Japon et qu'ils sont absolument
essentiel dans la fourniture en
électricité du pays qui ne peut pas
tourner bien évidemment dans le système
actuel sans avoir cette
électricité donc je le je le répète donc
nous avons un avion qui va pas partir
dès que possible de roissi pour le Japon
avec à son bord 3000 masques de
protection avec des cartouches des
combinaisons des gants de l'acide borque
que nous avons effectivement constitué
avec EDF et que nous sommes en train
d'acheminer sous sous logistique à rvin
euh nous avons fait partir en début de
semaine du matériel de mesure de la
radioactivité qui provient de notre
filiale cerra et le matériel dont nous
disposons à Tokyo et a bien é évidemment
été mis à disposition des équipes de
sécurité japonais alors nous avons fait
un don pour bien sûr tous les sinistrés
du tremblement de terre et du tsunami
sur lequel je ne reviendrai pas alors
moi je pense que face à ça ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens bah c'est
de la transparence la transparence et
l'assurance qu'effectivement nous
déployons et nous développons tous les
moyens que nous avons sur le maximum de
sûreté et de sécurité et je crois que
dans le contexte actuel euh tous les les
discussions qu'il il a pu y avoir sur le
fait que parfois le Pr était considéré
comme trop sûr paraisse légèrement
dérisoire et montre bien que le Paris
sur la sûreté et la sécurité et le Paris
de
l'avenir alors je pense également que
nous allons avoir en tant qu'industriel
et et bien évidemment avec Henri
progliot au premier chef nous avons bien
évidemment avoir besoin de de de de
reconstruire aussi un dialogue et une
confiance sur le nucléaire ça je crois
qu'il ne faut pas se faire sur le sujet
cette cette construction de la confiance
est absolument clé pour laavenir de nos
industrie et c'est bien sûr le sujet sur
lequel nous allons aussi
inlassablement développer le le dialogue
alors je l'ai dit beaucoup de fois dev
différents cénacles de vos assemblées
sûreté et sécurité ne se négoi pas ça a
toujours été effectivement notre notre
crédau et et notre certitude il faut
appliquer les normes les plus exigeantes
utiliser les meilleures technologies euh
merci de votre attention et et croyez
bien que nous sommes totalement dédiés à
la situation merci de ces précisions
Henri Revol président du Haut de conseil
vous avez été saisi par le Premier
ministre juste deux mots l'Office le
Haut Comité a été créé comme il a été
indiqué par la loi de 2006 il a été
installé il y a maintenant 2 ans et demi
il a déjà beaucoup travaillé puisqu'il a
été saisi comme la loi le permet par les
ministres ou par l'Office parlementaire
ou messieurs parmi les présidents des
par les présidents des commissions du
Parlement il peut également s'autosaisir
de toute question relative à l'impact
des activités nucléaires et de
l'information les concernant sur la
santé humaine et sur l'environnement il
se met donc à disposition de tous ceux
qui peuvent le saisir et éventuellement
il
s'autosaisira dans le cadre tout de tout
le processus qui a été indiqué tout à
l'heure par les ministres sur
l'évaluation de la sûreté de nos
installations face notamment aux
éléments naturels de séisme ou de
d'inondation merci est-ce que nous
pouvons ouvrir le débat l'ensemble des
parlementaires que je sens évidemment
impatient les co-présidents des groupes
d'études sur l'énergie souhaitent poser
des questions alors je serais vraiment
très satisfait si vous vous limitiez à
poser les questions en 2 minutes plutôt
les déclarations on déjà été fait par
nos groupes respectifs donc monsieur
Brot oui merci monsieur le Président
vous aurez noté que le président du
groupe socialiste a été extrêmement
concis tout à l'heure donc vous
m'autoriserez une petite minute de plus
et je vous en remercie les ministres
sont sont partis c'était prévu il y a
une réunion d'urgence il devront revenir
le président poignant s'y est engagé
devant nous parce que le débat sur la
stratégie énergétique doit avoir lieu
bienû sûr avec l'ensemble de la
population mais d'abord au Parlement et
nous avons des points de vues différents
sur la place du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique sur les filières de
renouvelaabes qui sont aujourd'hui assez
mal traités sur le manque d'engagement
dans l'efficacité énergétique sur le
manque de transparence le rapport rousli
faisait des liens un peu ce qu'ux
passez-moi l'expression entre les coûts
et la sécurité je n'y reviens pas mais
ça nous avait beaucoup ému à tel point
d'ailleurs que compteenu de l'indigence
ou pas dire plutôt le côté elliptique de
ce rapport pardon d'utiliser un gros mot
j'avais demandé au nom du groupe
socialiste que la commission des
affaires économiques de l'Assemblée
nationale traite de la question du
nucléaire au cours d'e de nombreuses
auditions le président poignant l'a
rappelé nous avons eu une dizaine de
séances de travail avec l'ensemble des
acteurs qui sont ici je renvoie
d'ailleurs à ceux qui n'y étaient pas
les compte-rendus de ces réunions qui
étaient publiques et nous avons par
exemple passé plusieurs heures sur la
question de cadarach qui a été évoqué
tout à l'heure pourquoi l'information a
mis du temps à remonter à l'Autorité de
sûreté bref le Parlement est
complètement impliqué dans ces questions
sans forcément le faire dans l'émotion
et dans l'urgence pour autant
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous tournés
vers l'épreuve terrible que vivent les
les Japonais je m'en tiendrai au niveau
des des questions à à ce
drame tout d'abord on a le sentiment que
c'est une catastrophe qui est vécu
devant un risque connu mais qui
peut-être a été
sous-évalué puisque il y a deux choses
il y a le tremblement de terre et puis
il y a le tsunami il semble je ne suis
pas technicien que si la vague avait été
moins haute on aurait pu continuer à à
amener de l'eau pour pour refroidir donc
comment est-ce que après autant d'études
autant de de pratiques dans ces domaines
on peut finalement entre guillemets
faire l'impasse sur une possibilité
comme celle-ci c'est ma première
question deuxème question qui vous
alimente parce que les uns et les autres
vous nous dites voilà on a des
informations par tel biais par tel autre
on a le sentiment que vous fonctionne
par recoupement et donc du coup il y a
plusieurs versions qui sont données on a
beaucoup de mal ici à s'y retrouver et à
comprendre puisque chaque fois qu'un
expert est est interviewé dans les
télévisions il dit des choses
complémentaires ou différentes ou
opposées à expert précédent donc ça pose
quand même un problème de savoir quelle
est la source de l'information 3ème
question j'ai dit que j'en avais quatre
sur les mesures de protection des
populations euh la question du
confinement est-ce que l'éloignement
vous avez déjà répondu 20 km vous dites
que c'est suffisant le confinement ça
doit durer combien de temps ça se passe
comment pour ne jamais sortir comment on
peut quand même être alimenté quelles
sont peut-être les conséquences malgré
le confinement pour les populations qui
sont concernées et puis la question de
liode aussi qui qui est posée quel usage
euh selon quelle modalité de
d'utilisation et une 4rième question qui
est directement liée à à à notre
territoire puisqu'il y a sur Internet
quelque chose qui circule alors le le
président de DF vient de l'évoquer sans
évoquer cette rumeur on nous dit sur
dans cette écrit que les rythmes les
risque pardon sismique auraiit été
sous-évalué pour la conception de nos de
nos centrales nucléaires je pense que
c'est très important que l'Autorité de
sûreté nous dise d'ors et déjà
aujourd'hui ce qu'il en est de la prise
en compte des risques sismiques sur dans
l'ensemble des centrales nucléaires du
pays c'est pas la question que je pose
au président de DF je pose des questions
aux responsables de l'Autorité de sûreté
merci de votre attention merci François
Claude Gatignol merci monsieur le
Président beaucoup de questions ont déjà
été posées et les ministres étant parti
je me limiterai à quelques questions en
destination de nos experts mais ils sont
elles sont ces questions motivé par le
souci pour la population les familles
les enfants et leur impact sanitaire et
la radioprotection sur ce qui va se se
dérouler maintenant puisque s'il y a un
temps pour le retour d'expérience les
uns et les autres on a bien dit qu'il
s'agissait tout de suite de mesures en
urgence à la fois pour le Japon mais
ensuite ensuite dans les mois qui
viendront les les jours peut-être et les
semaines pour ce qui concerne la
population française alors c'est vrai
que membrre du Haut Comité membrre des
trois CLIS de des des établissement de
ma propre circonscription vous
comprendrez que dès ce midi avec avec
quelques collègues nous avons dit à
l'ambassadeur du Japon toute la
compassion que nous avions pour la
situation vécue par ce ce pays alors moi
je voudrais poser quelques questions
suivantes euh comme François Brotte l'a
dit moi je voudrais savoir quels sont
les lien de communication que vous avez
avec les autorités japonaises on on a du
mal à à percevoir cette chose-là
deuxièmement euh si euh nous avons des
informations à quand aurons-nous les
véritables informations qui déterminent
quand même l'évolution de la situation
alors sur la nature des dégâts et et
leur
gravité on a bien compris que les les
diesels de secours étaient semblé hors
d'état sur l'état de chacun des réacteur
concerné les 1 le 2 et le 3 dans son
enceinte son combustible son niveau
d'eau sa cuve et la fameuse piscine qui
contient le le cœur déchargé alors à
partir de là des rejets sont
l'atmosphère est-ce qu'on les connaît
exactement la nature des rayons
nucléides est-ce qu'on connaît
exactement la météo qui va
conditionner les risques éventuels liés
à ces rejets sur les personnels
d'intervention d'abord sur les
populations du Japon et pour ses voisins
immédiats et alors en ce qui concerne la
situation de la France Monsieur le
Président que limiter les questions sans
les commentaires mon chers collègue s
vous plaît pour savoir quand seront
détectés les premières parcelles de
rejet et quant à notre parc nucléaire
sera ma dernière question nous avons
régulièrement déjà des audits des
analyses des pires reviews alors est-ce
qu'on peut déjà avoir un état des lieux
sachant que comme on l'a dit cette
relation de la société avec l'énergie
atomique est fondée non pas sur la peur
ni sur la démagogie mais surtout sur la
connaissance la transparence qui est le
gage de la confiance bien avant que vous
ne répondiez je vais donner la parole à
au sénateur Ladislas ponatovski
président du groupe d'études de
l'énergie du Sénat merci monsieur le
Président oui juste deux questions
toutes les deux au président de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire la
première monsieur le Président
concernant la gestion
post-accidentelle bon le le nuage
radioactif n'est pas terminé il va
vraisemblablement s'aggraver mais déjà
se pose toute une série de questions
bien précises les populations évacué
vont-elles pouvoir revenir est-ce que ce
sont des zones qui vont être
définitivement évacué va-t-on pouvoir
cultiver va-t-on pouvoir reconstruire je
dis ça parce que monsieur le Président
la France s'est déjà posé les questions
ces questions là et en 2005 il vous a
été demandé un rapport sur ce qui se
passerait dans nos centrales dans un tel
cas de figure exactement ces questions
comment y répondre il vous avait été
donné 2 ans pour répondre en 2007 vous
avez demandé une prolongation pour de
très bonnes raisons parce que le travail
que vous avez commencé vous l'avez fait
d'une manière très sérieuse vous avez
créé des sous-groupes de travail et vos
différents experts ont fait un travail
très important mais aujourd'hui nous
l'avons toujours pas donc ma question
est toute ce cette gestion
postaccidentelle où en est votre
réflexion pour s'il y a demain une
catastrophe naturelle dans une de nos
centrales sur notre territoire 2è
question l'audit annoncé par le Premier
ministre et qui vous a demandé quel
est-il exactement je voudrais faire un
lien entre l'audit et le problème de la
prolongation de durée de vie des
centrales nucléaires cet audit quel
est-il quel temps allez-vous y
consacré dans combien de temps
allez-vous pouvoir nous donner des
éléments de réponse et est-ce que le
travail que vous allez faire pour
l'audit va être un travail qui vous
allez pouvoir utiliser pour cette second
mission qui est la vôtre la prolongation
de durée de vie de chacune des centrales
car il serait logique qu'il y ait un
lien même si le premier problème est un
problème à court terme et l'autre est un
problème à moyen et long
terme pour l'équilibre des assemblées
daniel
Raoul merci monsieur le Président la la
question fondamentale que je me pose je
me projette déjà dans le retour
d'expérience et pas simplement sur
l'aspect géographique qu'évoquait notre
collègue patski sur les retombées et
cetera mais quelles sont les
conséquences que peuvent avoir cette
catastrophe sur entre autres le prix de
la reine et il ne serait pas ne
serait-il pas nécessaire de revisiter ce
qu'on a imposé à certains qui auraient
accès dans l'investissement privé
autrement dit peut-on confier en fait à
un groupe privé ou partiellement
privatisé la gestion et les mesures de
maintenance et de prévention de de la
sûreté nucléaire c'est relativement
clair ça peut poser un certain nombre de
problèmes mais en tous les cas je
souhais la
poser alors après cette question ces
quatre questions vous pouvez répondre
tout de suite monsieur
Lacoste monsieur le Président je
répondrai je répondrai à toutes ces
questions bien sûr sachant queun
questions
sont suffisamment général pour
s'adresser à d'autres acteurs qu'à
moi-même
je reprendrai d'abord la question de
l'analyse de ce qui se passe au Japon
nous sommes encore en pleine
crise donc nous sommes pas encore dans
la gestion du pocident nous crise je
crois qu'il faut que chacun comprenne
bien que la seule proccupation no collèg
japonais actuellement quel que soit
le leur statut c'est d'arriver à
apporter de l'eau sur les installations
C c'est vraent la seule préoccupation
tout le reste est radicalementon
alors cela dit c'est parmi les questions
que nous poserons ensuite il y a une
question que je formule de la façon
suivante est-ce que l'origine de ce qui
se passe au Japon c'est version extrême
qu'on a sous-estimé le séisme qu'on a
sousestimé le tsunami je ne crois pas
l'expérienceement que les
bâtiments nucléair ont résisté au C
peut-être il un oou ramènet-on le
problème simplement au fait que les
Japonais sont moins rigoureux que nous
ont apparemment été moins rigoureux que
nous sur les systèmes électriques
secours mais le fait que je puisse poser
des problèmes avec une telle ampleur de
réponse possible montre bien que il faut
que nous nous donnions le temps de
l'analyse et que nous ne nous
précipitions
pas au-delà de ça en ce qui concerne
l'ASN en comptepartie notre indépendance
nous avons un devoir absolu de
transparence et je crois vraiment sur
cette crise comme sur tout le reste nous
disons tout ce que nous savons euh il va
falloir que nous répondions à plusieurs
demandes il y a une demande
d'audit qui a été formulé par le
gouvernement il y a une annonce de
quelque chose d'un peu analogue sous
forme de test au niveau européen qui ont
été évoqués hier après-midi à Bruxelles
JT mais qui reste encore à définir comme
le dit et par ailleurs nous avons en
cours un processus d'analyse de la
possibilité de prolonger la durée
d'exploitation des racteurs bon il faut
que nous mettions tout ça ensemble
sachant qu'encore une fois notre volonté
d'être aussi transparent que possible et
quand je dis transparent c'est parce que
il est notre devoir de rendre compte au
Parlement nous sommes aussi clairs que
possible sur ce que nous trouvons au
inspection nous avons volontairement
demandé à bénéficier d'un audit
international en 2006 hein un audit irrs
mené sous l'égie de laua nous l' avons
experts étrangers dans le groupe
permanent d'expert donc vraiment nous
sommes aussi ouverts que possible il
nous faut réussir à rendre cohérents les
différentes demandes qui nous sont
adressées nous le ferons avec l'appui de
l'IRSN et je vous garantis que nous
serons extraordinairement explicites
enfin aussi explicit que nous nous
sommes sur l'ensemble de ce que nous
faisons donnons-nous simplement le temps
de réfléchir au cahier des charges à
l'évidence nous répondrons mais
réfléchissons au cahier des charges et
encore une fois il y a un premier temps
ben je dirais laisser nos collègues
japonais gérer la crise l'analyser et
voir ce qui en en sort voilà ce que je
tenais à dire
là-dessus je dis un mot de la question
que vous l'avez posé sur les gestions
post-occidentelles à ma connaissance la
France est la seule à avoir eu le
courage de se lancer une réflexion sur
le poste accidentelle quand nous
cherchons des références ailleurs nous n
trouvons pas et nos collègues étrangers
viennent voir chez nous la réflexion en
cours c'est réflexion initiée en 2005 on
l' projet en 2007 mais nous l'avons tenu
en 2008 un collocque international nous
aurons un nouveau collocque
international sur ce thème en juin de
cette
année avec de nouveau partage de de nos
conclusions c'est un processus long et
difficile parce que la matière est
complexe et parce que c'est pas un
travail technocratique n l'avons mené en
liaison là aussi avec les r nous l'
avons souhaité associer l'ensemble des
parties prenantes nous avons un certain
nombre de débats qui ont lieu dans la
région nous associons les populations
nous associons lespul les l'association
mais encore une fois travail fondamental
sur lesquels la France globalement est
tout à fait pionnière alors n narons
peut-être pas à des décisions ou des
formulations extraordinairement
éclatantes mais nous aurons avancé dans
la détermination ce qu'il vaut à faire
sur des sujets fondamentaux comme dans
quelles conditions autorise- tons le
retour des populations vous l'avez
vous-même
évoqué j'en viens à un autre point qui a
été posé de façon répétée c'est de
quelle source d'information
disposons-nous je dirais nous disposons
d'une batterie de source d'information
que nous nous efforçons de mettre en
commun alors la source d'information
c'est dans chacun des cas nos collègues
nos homologues nos sources
d'information c'est l'attaché nucléaire
de
l'ambassade de France à Tokyo nos
sources d'information sont celles que ca
a via son homologue nos sources
d'information ce sont des personnes que
nous connaissons je peux citer le cas en
ce qui concerne l'ASN de contact que
nous avons directement avec un ancien
commissaire de la nucléer Safety
Commission et qui se trouve suffisamment
dégagé des choses pour porter un regard
en même temps avisé critique sur ce qui
se passe et c'est tout ça que nous
mettons en gerbe de façon à avoir
l'information la plus fiable alors quand
l'information est j suffisamment fiable
nous disons voilà ce qui nous semble
avérer quand c'est pas assez fiable ben
nous disons voilà ce que nous croyons
savoir et nous nous gardons comme la
Pest de nous fonder sur des rumeurs nous
pouvons pas nous appuyer sur des rumeurs
comme il y a un porte-avion qui est
passé au large de la centrale et voilà
ce qui s'est passé nous pourons pas nous
fier à telle ou telle mesure de
radioactivité don nous ne savons pas où
elle a été faite nous pourons pas nous
fier à ça ça a été indiqué là également
par Jacques repissard donc nous nous
efforçons de bâtir une connaissance
aussi possible qu'il est ce possible
dans un contexte qui est le contexte
difficile où nos homologues les uns aux
autres ont pour premier souci de gérer
la crise et mettons-nous leur place
mettons-nous leur place
pass monsur ça je dirais peut-être un
mot sur un point particulier qui est le
risque sismique là là il faut être
clair le risque sismique en France est
traité de façon extrêmement sérieuse la
France est un pays où le risque sismique
est modéré mais il existe il existe
surtout dans un nombre limité de régions
il est traité très sérieusement alors
comment est-il traité le premier point
est d'évaluer l'importance de risque
donc on regarde tout ce qu'on peut
réunir comme élevant d'information sur
ce risque ça consiste en particulier à
regardarder les cilmes qui sont
intervenus historiquement je prends
l'exemple de fheim on regarde ce qui
s'est passé autour de F et et du
Faussier Renant un des ses que nous
prenons en compte c'est le séisme qui a
frappé balle en 1356 voyez on remonte
loin on regarde ce qu'on appelle les
paléocéismes c'est S dont on a perdu la
trace historique mais qu'on retrouve par
la
géologie on fait une mal de tout ça on
s'est dit voilà le séisme le plus
important qui est intervenu et on fait
deux choses ensuite le S on place à
l'endroit on place hypothétiquement à
l'endroit où il ferait le plus de dégâts
à l'installation voyez on maximise par
CEL et on multiplie la puissance du C le
plus fort connu par 5 et on dit la
centrale ou l'installation do résister à
ça on le fait au départ quand
l'installation est construite et puis
régulièrement on se demande s'il faut
réévaluer la la seismique par suite du
progrès des connaissances c'est ce que
nous faisons également régulièrement et
à ce moment-là on demande à ant EDF le
CVA de renforcer la résistance au céis
donc je considère c'est vrai qu'on fait
très sérieusement ce qu'il faut en
matière de séisme avec prise en compte
de marches considérable mais encore une
fois j'admets parfaitement que nous
revisitions ça hein nous sommes tout à
fait ouverts à ce que ce soit regardé à
ce que ce soit examiné nons aucune
raison d'avoir honte de ce que nous
avons fait nous sommes à la recherche de
projet technique nous le ferons
oui jacus ça pour la suite des réponses
merci monsieur le Président alors
j'enchaîne sur le les aspects sismiques
je partage tout à fait fait ce qui vient
d'être dit par monsie lacos j'ajoute que
le il circule sur l'Internet des des
informations selon lesquels enfin qui
pose la question de savoir pourquoi le
système de sûreté nucléaire n'utilise
pas les les référentiels qui sont en
train d'être constru à l'échelle
européenne pour les installations C
vaisau où il y a une carte de l'aléa
sismique et ensuite des prescriptions
pour les
constructions la la vérité c'est que les
exigences nucléaires alors elles sont
conçues sur un modèle intellectuel un
peu différent qu' qu'a décrit dans le
détail monsieur Lacoste mais euh notre
avis est que les exigences dans le
nucléaire sont bien supérieures à ce que
va faire cette réforme pour les site
cvzo qui était un niveau très beaucoup
plus bas qui va être rehaussé mais sans
atteindre pour autant les exigences du
système nucléaire alors il y a un
problème de communication c'est
qu'effectivement nous tenons à préserver
les acquis du système nucléaire français
qui est différent de ce système européen
qui est en fait des tiné à mieux
encadrer des constructions génie civil
classique donc ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faudra qu'on
qu'on communique davantage parce qu'il y
a l'opinion publique les observateurs
pourrai se demander pourquoi il y a ce
particularisme nucléaire et est-ce qu'il
est justifié j'joute que une des
particularités de la prise en compte du
C dans le domaine nucléaire c'est que
nous faisons étude site à site site par
site nous ne comptons pas de données
régional nous venons étude site par
site j'en viens maintenant quelques
précisions mentaire sur les sur la radio
protection suite au l'accident du Japon
la protection des populations françaises
alors d'abord les premiers concernés
sont évidemment les membres de la
Communauté française au Japon et l'IRSN
a fourni au gouvernement il y a eu
plusieurs réunions plus niveau de l'État
sur ce qu'il fallait faire et des
recommandations ont été formulées par
l'IRSN et reprises par l'ambassade
s'agissant de de la Communauté française
au Japon les les les recommandations
sont simples elles ont été rendu public
il s'agit d'abord parce qu'il y a un
risque de de nouveau séisme et puis
parce qu'il y a potentiellement un
risque de de d'aggravation
de de la contamination atmosphérique
donc les recommandations sont aux
familles euh et aux personnes qui n'ont
pas absolument besoin d'être là de
d'aller quelques temps dans le sud de
l'archipel ou bien de rentrer en France
et pour les personnes soit qui ne
souhaitent pas rester pour des raison
familial par exemple soit parce que le
travail doit se poursuivre et
l'ambassade doit fonctionner les
entreprises au Japon doivent fonctionner
et euh les Japonais travaillent et il
y'y a pas de raison que les Français
plient bagage sur le plan professionnel
donc nous avons simplement recommandé
que euh on prenne quelques précautions
comme par exemple éviter de de sortir
quand il pleut se pour ne pas contaminer
éventuellement des vêtements de se euh
mettre à la de de se mettre à l'abri si
les situations s'aggrav et euh des des
compriés médiodes ont été distribué mais
je dois dire que c'est une mesure de
précaution et et quelque part de
réassurance vis-à-vis de nos
compatriotes qui font le choix h ou qui
sont obligés de rester nous nous nos
estimations sont que il ne sera jamais
nécessaire de consommer ces comprimés
mais c'est une mesure de réassurance en
quelque sorte qui est tout à fait
légitime alors s'agissant maintenant des
des autres partis enfin des du
territoire français donc il a été
question de l'outreem tout à l'heure et
de la France
métropolitaine il y aura pas de risque
sanitaire pas plus qu'il n en a eu lors
des des épisodes de liés aux armes
nucléaires et le délai hein les délais
sont sont sont élevés donc par exemple
pour arriver jusqu'à Tokyo le délai
entre Fukushima et et Tokyo c'est délai
c'est de l'ordre de 20 25 à 30 HE donc
les délais pour atteindre la côte
américaine la côte ouest puis la côteest
puis Saint-Pierre et miclon on parle de
semaine pendant ce temps-là l'IRSN a
fine ses modèles nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied et nous allons commencer
à publier dans les tout prochains jours
là nous avons maintenant des rassemblé
toutes les informations qui étaient
nécessaires pour fond F une modéisation
sur quelque chose d'à peu près sérieux
nous l'avons recoupé avec nos collègues
du CEA nous sommes en train de le faire
avec les les Américains les Japonais on
peut pas se permettre de publier des
choses qui seraient complètement
contradictoires donc on les informations
sont parcellaires encore une fois comme
ça a été rappelé par Monsieur Lacoste
donc nous faisons attention et donc
c'est pour ça que nous avons nous
prenons de précautions avant de sortir
des cartes et nous mais lorsque le
système sera lancé nous alimenterons ces
cartes en fonction de la météo réelle et
des points de mesure que nous pourrons
avoir ici ou là de manière sérieuse à
travers la planète et en particulier aux
États-Unis nous aurons des données
fiables qui nous permettront de mieux
caler nos modèles dans quelques temps
voilà et tout ça sera rendu public bien
entendu voilà je ne sais pas s'il y a
s'il y a d'autres questions auquelles
écout on on va peut-être passer à à
d'autres questions monsieur Miard
d'abord puis monsieur bataille puis oui
oui d'accord merci monsieur le Président
ma question risque de faire peut-être
sourire les ingénieurs mais dans
l'opinion publique la grande crainte
c'est que ce réacteur qui est en
surchauffe explose tel entre guillemets
une bombe atomique est-ce que ça c'est
un scénario possible dès lors que
malheureusement il n'est plus refroidi
et là je crois que l'opinion publique
attend un un certain nombre de
précisions bataille oui ma question va
porter sur le le devenir des réacteurs
qu'on a très très peu évoqué
finalement je crois que le devenir du du
nucléaire civil au moins à l'horizon de
50 ans dépend d'une évolution vers plus
de sûreté alors ma question se tourne à
la fois vers monsieur Lacoste et vers
les les industriels quelle va être le
devenir de
l'pr qui est un réacteur plus sûr mais
auquel on reproche les industriels
reprochent son coût excessif quel va
être le devenir de l'atma actuellement à
à l'étude encore
en en recherche quel va être aussi le
devenir des réacteurs de faible
puissance dont on dit qu'ils ont le
défaut de
multiplier les sites et enfin pour ce
qui est
de la génération 4 où en eston des
recherches sur
Astrid le retour vers les surgénérateurs
en quelque sorte que nous avons arrêté
en France à travers super phenniix je
sais bien que chacune de ces questions
mériterait un un long exposé mais je
veux savoir si il y a de la
détermination du côté de l'autorité de
sûreté d'aller vers plus de sûreté et
notamment je voudrais demander à
Monsieur Lacoste ce qu'il pense des
réacteurs lowcost que l'on a annoncé et
du programme de recherche
franco-chinois coopération
franco-chinoise qui irait vers la mise
au point d'un réacteur d'une génération
antérieure un de plus qui ne coûterait
pas cher mais qui serait beaucoup moins
sûr va-t-on vers en somme une
normalisation
internationale ou bien est-ce impossible
est-ce que la France qui montre
l'exemple avec le Pr en matière de
sûreté va être va continuer au plan
international à être concurrencé par des
réacteurs coréens aujourd'hui peut-être
chinois demain meilleur marché moins sûr
on ne peut que s'inquiéter de cette
évolution j'en ai terminé monsieur
président ensuite monsieur
dor
merci Président je crois
qu'effectivement bon nos nos regards
sont tournés vers le Japon et vers cette
terrible catastrophe mais depuis
quelques jours cela est déplacé sur
notre territoire en
France certains responsables ou
certaines personnalités depuis il y a 48
he ou 24 oui 48h on fait des
déclarations qui sont des déclarations
qui peuvent inquiéter nos populations en
particulier en exigeant la fermeture
immédiate de plusieurs centrales et je
suis l'élu d'un territoire territoire de
Gen encadré par la centrale de
Belleville et la centrale de Dampierre
il est bien évident que lorsque l'on a
entendu hier l'exigence par certains
responsables de la fermeture de cette
centrale il y a eu des inquiétudes qui
se sont fait jour je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce débat puisque nous
sommes quand même sous observations des
médias et de la population
et je vais poser la question donc à
Monsieur Lacoste et Monsieur progliot de
savoir réellement quelle réponse
apporter à ces populations et aux
questions qui me sont posées monsieur
chassigne
oui je vous remercie tout d'abord une
observation mais qui vaut quand même
question puisque la le japonais Tepco
est la première compagnie privée
d'électricité du monde et force de
constater que d'avril à décembre 2010
euh les profits ont été de 1,19
milliards d'euros quand une perte à peu
près équivalente l'année précédente on
peut toujours se poser la question d'où
vient reddressement aussi spectaculaire
même si on va pas apporter la réponse
aujourd'hui je m'interroge sur le fait
que le nucléaire soit géré par des
entreprises privées qui sont à la
recherche de profit est-ce que ça peut
pas se faire au détriment d'une forme de
sécurité manque d'entretien notamment
2uxè question c'est un constat qui nous
a été fait lors d'audition il semblerait
qu'en France la sous-trait
dans les centrales soit extrêmement
importante que cette sous-traitance
provoque des incidents minimes mais
nombreux et que si ces incidents minimes
mais nombreux se passaient sur le même
site il pourrai devenir particulièrement
grave et on nous dit que c'est dû à un
manque de formation du personnel que
c'est dû aussi à l'utilisation de
matériaux qui sont de mauvaise qualité
je crois que ça pose véritablement la
question du contrôle des sous-traitants
est-ce que c affire là ne doit pas être
tenu par les entreprises privées et avec
en particulier une rigueur quant aux
personnes qui interviennent merci
Monsieur chasseille monsieur
Lesterlin merci monsieur le Président ma
question pourrait s'adresser autant au
au président desdf coresponsable de la
sûreté nucléaire sur deux points est-ce
que le fait de construire sur un même
site et à proximité plusieurs réacteur
augmentent les risques est-ce que c'est
le cas de Fukushima
et comment le problème se pose chez nous
et deuxème question sur la localisation
on comprend que les bords de mer ou de
fleuve sont retenus pour des raisons
évidentes d'accès au refroidissement par
l'eau mais quand on sait que même dans
un pays tempéré comme le nôtre il peut y
avoir des BL 99 ou des xinti
2010 y a-t-il des alternatives de
localisation par rapport à ces
risques
merci Monsieur Jean-Pierre Nicolas merci
monsieur le Président on a beaucoup
parlé technique je n je je n'y
reviendrai pas simplement dans la
gestion immédiate de ce qu'il faut bien
appeler une catastrophe quels sont les
les mesures qui ont été prises pour
protéger la population j'ai bien compris
on a bien compris que les périmètres
d'évacuation étaient passés de 20 km à
30 km est-ce que c'est suffisant est-ce
que ce confinement sera suffisant est-ce
qu'il faudra aller au-delà je je suis
pas certain qu'on
soit à l'heure actuelle en mesure d'y
répondre mais les Japonais disposent-il
suffisamment
d'équipement individuel si
éventuellement il fallait en arriver là
pour pouvoir protéger d'une manière
efficace les populations je prendrai un
exemple un peu un peu bateau disposons
suffisamment de pastill de pastilles
diodes
pour dispenser à la popul l'ensemble de
la population qui en aurait besoin j'ai
bien compris tout à l'heure quand no
vergeon disait qu'il y avait un avion
qui était prêt à décoller pour apporter
du matériel de protection euh euh aux
Japonais l'ont-ils demandé merci Madame
Catherine procacia
sénatrice euh merci les le premier jour
de ces catastrophe euh enfin du
tremblement de terre et du tsunami sur
les médias on parlait de plusieurs
centrale nucléaire donc j'aimerais
savoir maintenant tout se concentre sur
une seule centrale s'il y a des risques
sur d'autres centrales euh la deuxième
question correspond au au moyens de
lutte j'avais le sentiment qu'il y avait
des robots qui pouvaient remplacer les
hommes mais est-ce que ce sont des
problèmes de circuit électrique qui font
que maintenant ce sont simplement des
hommes qui peuvent intervenir et non
plus des robots et la troisème et
dernière question concerne les vent vous
nous avez tous dit que ça allait vers le
Pacifique et que ça restait dans le même
hémisphère mais tons sûr que ça ne peut
pas
aller dans l'autre sens et aller par
exemple sur l'ouest et non pas sur
l'Est oui merci Monsieur Le Bouillonnec
merci monsieur le Président ma question
rejoint celle de notre collègue Miard
que se passera-t-il ou que peut-il se
passer si les opérations de
refroidissement étaient vaines sur le
site lui-même et du du même coup quelles
seraient les conséquences de ce que vous
allez nous décrire sur l'ensemble de la
chirpelle et de la population et sur les
territoires français à proximité entre
guillemets mais qui à un moment donné
sont les plus proches de
l'archipel Monsieur François puponi oui
pour déjà pour bien comprendre la manè
s'est passé selon vous est-ce que tous
les incidents et accidents qui ont que
dont nous avons parlé sont dusû au
tremble TER ou au tsunami parce qu'il
est important de savoir les raisons pour
lesquelles tout cela est intervenu et et
et par rapport à ce qui a été dit est-ce
que d'autres centrales auraient pu être
endommagé actuellement au Japon sans
qu'on ait forcément l'information si oui
lesquel et et et
troisièmement par rapport au au moyens
d'intervention vous nous dites qu'il
faut effectivement refroidir refroidir
amener de l'eau de l'eau et le problème
c'est qu'effectivement si un moment on
n'est plus en capacité de le faire euh
donc combien dein combien de temps après
un événement encore plus grave pourrait
intervenir madame Frédérique
Massa merci monsieur le Président en
août 2005 un sismologue japonais qui
faisait partie du comité d'experts
chargés d'établir les Nores sismiques
des centrales a déclaré à moins que des
mesures radicales ne soient prises pour
réduire la vulnérabilité des centrales
au tremblement de terre le Japon
pourrait vivre un vrai catastrophe
nucléaire dans un futur proche ça a été
dit en août 2007 donc à savoir si euh
par rapport à ces propos euh vous avez
été éventuellement informé ou alors si
ce sont des rumeurs l'agence
international de l'énergie atomique
aurait aussi averti le Japon des
problèmes de sécurité sur ces centrales
en cas de
risque sismique ma question est de
savoir quel rôle et quel pouvoir que
peut avoir l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique concernant les règles
de sûreté nucléaire international et
également par rapport notamment à laasn
en particulier eu égard alors c'est
certainement beaucoup trop tôt mais par
rapport au drames que vit le Japon
allez-vous vous avoir des exigences
supérieures par rapport à la surité
nucléaire de notre pays monsur
Jean-Pierre Brar merci monsieur le
Président d'abord moi je souhaiterais
qu'on nous abonde dans l'information l'
RSN laasn nous avons déjà reçu un
certain nombre moi personnellement j'ai
mis ça sur mon site parce que nos
concitoyens souhaitent savoir et je
crois que contenu de la qualité des les
informations je sais pas si elles sont
complètes qu'on nous a donné c'est utile
de même monsieur le Président le texte
de du débat aujourd'hui si c'est pris je
crois que si très rapidement on pouvait
avoir le texte inextino ça serait très
utile deuxièmement
euh évidemment nous sommes des
responsables politiques nous avons le
devoir de réfléchir à ce qui se passe
aussi d'anticiper l'avenir et je
voudrais avoir l'avis de nos
interlocuteurs qui n non pas seulement
une réflexion sur le nucléaire j'imagine
mais qui une vision plus globale des
problèmes énergétiques et moi j'ai
autant de compassion pour quelqu'un qui
meurt irradié que pour quelqu'un qui
meurt de la silicose ou bien de la
désertification du fait du réchauffement
climatique
et moi je
suis dans le débat par exemple avec nos
collègues allemands qui contribuent au
réchauffement climatique CIN fois plus
que la France ça n'igne personne je suis
très étonné et je pense qu'il y a un
piège dans lequel nous risquons de
tomber c'est de limiter le débat
aujourd'hui au nucléaire mourir c'est
toujours mourir et donc il faut
s'intéresser me semble-t-il à tous les
risques et ne pas tomber dans cette
agitation qui permet à certains
d'occuper les lucarnes dans la
télévision mais qui les honore pas
nécessairement nous devons avoir une
vision non seulement pour notre pays
mais pour le futur de notre humanité et
nous sommes en droit de discuter
fermement avec les Chinois les Polonais
les Allemands euh pour les risques dans
lesquel il plonge euh l'humanité sans
avoir de compte à rendre à personne pour
l'instant je pense en particulier à nos
amis Allemands et les Américains aussi
d'ailleurs comme quelqu'un le souffle
donc moi je souhaiterait avoir l' vie de
nos invités et il me semble que le débat
n'est pas seulement porte sur la
politique énergétique mais n'est pas
seulement de nature environnementale
mais aussi porte sur des questions qui
touchent à l'indépendance nationale
enfin dernier point monsieur le
Président les efforts de recherche il y
a une question que je n'ai pas entendu
évoquer depuis le début de la
catastrophe japonaise c'est la question
des déchets et quelle est la réflexion
qu'on peut avoir pour pousser la
recherche je pense au déchets
nucléaaires bien sûr euh la recherche
pour aller plus loin et on sait bien que
EDF arriva dans le passé je le dis très
franchement avec toute l'amitiés que
j'ai pour nos interlocuteurs n'ont pas
toujours été exemplaires pour la
transparent je me rappelle très bien 5
ans après chernoby j'étais à chernoby et
EDF avait lancé pour le 5e anniversaire
une campagne de communication pour
justifier sans explication le nucléaire
et je pense qu'il faut pas confondre
explication transparence et
propagande merci Monsieur
BR est-ce qu'il y a encore on répond
maintenant oui alors
Monsieur monsieur Cochet une question
encore c'est c'est des questions j'avais
posé des questions aux ministres
maintenant je pose des questions aux
autorités et aux industriels j'ai
d'ailleurs une question pour chacun
d'entre eux alors d'abord à Monsieur
Repussard d'abord à Monsieur Repussard
qui a dit il a comparé les émanations
éventuelles de radio éléments
actuellement à Fukishima avec dis ont
les essais nucléaires atmosphériques non
il faut comparer ça avec Chernobil
d'ailleurs je me fiche à Monsieur
Barouin qui ce matin même au sortir du
Conseil des ministres a dit dans le pire
des scénario ça pourrait être également
pire que tchernoby dans ce cas-là les
noages et bien ça n'est pas ceux des
bombes atomiques d'il y a 40 ans c'est
du type tchernoby qui à l'époque en
France par Monsieur pèlerin avait été
nié dépassé la frontière de l'Allemagne
bien donc c'est une pour moi une
question comparons ce qui est comparable
alors maintenant la question à Monsieur
à à Areva en ce qui concerne ce que j'ai
bien aimé d'ailleurs le discours de
madame levergon qui a théorisé ce que
nous avons dit nous depuis longtemps ce
qu'on peut appeler le droit d'ingérance
écologique très bien Madame l'auvergeon
mais je vous pose maintenant une
question il se trouve que vous avez
vendu du
MOX à Tepco et notamment pour le
réacteur numéro 3 de Fukushima alors que
une étude qui a été menée par Monsieur
le Professeur Liman qui est directeur
scientifique du nucleéar Center nuclear
cctor Institute à Washington en
1999 indiquait que sur Télé réacteurs à
eau bouillante notamment et bien le
risque d'un le risque était supérieur à
cause disons de la vivacité du MOX par
rapport euh à l'oxyde d'uranium habituel
voilà la question arriva pourquoi avoir
vendu du MOOC savoir qu'une étude
scientifique montrait que c'était plus
dangereux alors une question à EDF il se
trouve que le 2 novembre 2009 l'ASN avec
deux autres autorités de sur
a remis en cause la conception même du
système de contrôle commande notamment
l'indépendance de ces des réacteurs pr
et l'ASN a formulé 11 demandes précises
à EDF par exemple celle d'examiner les
dispositions de conception différentes
question F est-ce que ces 11 demandes
proposées par la SN ont été étudié
est-ce que du coup d'ailleurs le système
disons de contrôle commande durct repè a
été fondamentalement changé selon ces
recommandations enfin une autre question
question la dernière à laasn il n'a pas
été répondu je crois que Monsieur Brot
en a parlé c'est ce qui s'est passé à
cadarche pour la sousévaluation des
stocks de plutonium dans l'atelier MOX
est-ce que là aussi vous vous expliquez
cette non transparence dans le temps
puisque il a fallu attendre plusieurs
mois entre la constatation de cette
sous-évaluation du plutonium et le fait
qu'il a été rendu public
oui Monsieur Philippe folot et puis
peut-être que vous pourriez nous
expliquer entre le nuage type Tchernobyl
et un nuage de type explosion nucléaire
aérienne si pour les populations qui
reçoivent le nuage il y a une différence
et laquelle monsieur
folot oui monsieur le Président c'est
c'est un peu le sens de de ma question
parce qu'en fait le nucléaire je veux
dire il y a une dimension militaire il y
a une dimension production d'énergie et
puis a le nucléaire je veux dire civil
quotidien avec tous les instruments de
radio et et autres et que par rapport à
cela au niveau de de de vos différents
de vos différents organismes est-ce que
vous intervenez sur l'ensemble du
spectre et et ensuite est-ce que
notamment par rapport au petit petit
matériel donc de de de radiographie et
et autres un peu dissiminé partout
parfois oublié est-ce que est-ce que
cela fait partie des des éléments que
vous suivez
merci messieurs je vous laisse le soin
de répondre et de vous partager les
réponses non 'oubliez
pas simplement pour pour initier le
processus de réponse sachant qu'il a un
certain nombre de questions de porté
général je commencerai par la la
question de l'évolution vers plus de
sûreté il me semble qu'il y a deux deux
différences de fond entre le système
japonais tel que je le connais et
système français nous avons plus un
souci de transparence pour un certain
nombre de raisons don dont une partie
sont des raisons liées à la société et
nous avons davantage le souci d'un
progret continu en matière de sûreté
alors ça se traduit par le fait que les
exigigen de sûreté qui ont été imposé
aux différents éotents français en
particul DF au fil du temps ont
progressé sont Durc certains ont dit
elles ont empiré elles sont elles sont
durcies et actuellement ce que nous
demandons pour la construction en France
euh ce sont les un niveau c'est un
niveau de sûreté correspondant à
génération 3 ou correspondant àpr mais
ça je dirais c'est la conception
française ça n'a que la vertu d'une
conception française l'étape franchie
récemment a été que ceci est devenu
accepté au niveau européen via euh un
club responsable d'autorité surté qui
s'appelle WENRA Western European
nucléire regulatur association qui a dit
ben voilà quels sont les objectifs de
sûreté des nouveaux réacteurs à
construire en Europe il ressement
beaucoup aux objectifs sûreté de
réacteur p je dis bien aux objectifs en
termes généraux pas en termees de moyens
et il a été dit ben c'est vis-à-vis de
ces objectifs sûrté qu'on doit améliorer
la sûreté des reeurs existants et ça me
paraît tout à fait traduit à la
conception que nous avons du progrès en
la matière par ailleurs l'autorité
sûreté nucléaire a bien indiqué qu'elle
n'imaginait pas que dans le monde il
soit vendu sous le drapeau français des
réacteurs ne correspondant pas à ce
niveau de seté alors deuxème ensemble de
questions elle porte plutôt sur le Japon
des questions ont été posées sur
l'origine de ce qui se passe au Japon
encore une fois si voulez tremblement de
terre sûrement mais on a le sentiment
que les bâtiments nucléaires ont résisté
tsunami sûrement problème d'alimentation
de secours sûrement mais là on entre
déjà dans dans l'analyse qui sera à
faire et et qui mènera à du retour
d'expérience sur un ensemble de
questions portant sur ce que les
autorités japonaises font confinement je
je je et et euh mise à l'abri ça nous
paraît raisonnable en l'état actuel des
choses mais sans doute ces mesures
seront-elles durci au cours du temps si
la situation évolue équipement
individuel passidod j'ai visiter
suffisamment de centres d'intervention
au Japon pour être tout à fait sûr
qu'ils sont parfaitement équipés en tout
équipement toute nature donc point j'ai
pas d'inquiétude moyen d'intervention
Jea c'est au japonais de demander des
moyens d'intervention supplémentaires
s'il le souhaitent mais c'est à eux de
le demander c'est pas nous qui allons
prendretiative d'envoyer par avion des
choses dont il n'aurait pas le besoin et
pas la demande pu dernier point les vent
c'est une chose que nous maîtrisons pas
c'est
clair alors y a-t-il des risques
supplémentaires dans un site où il y a
plusieurs réacteurs non il peut y avoir
même des avantages plus réacteurs ça
permet d'avoir des moyens d'intervention
plus important ça permet de mutualiser
les moyens que sil passé à BL 2
clairement il y avait sousévaluation de
risque d'inondation mais là aussi
gardons raison l'événement de BL un
début d'inondationons classé au niveau
de l'échelle nous sommes tout à fait
hors de ce qui s pass au Japon et je
crois que clairement il a été reconnu
par l'exploitant EDF et par l'Autorité
de sûreté que nous avionions sous
estimer ce risque bah c'est la
transparence c'est la reconnaissance des
faits quand on est pris en défaut et
c'est la volonté de
progresser voilà ce que je souit dire en
notant c'est un point qui m'a tout à
fait frappé à titre personnel quand
monsieur BR a fait allusion aux
personnes qui meurent la silicose je me
suis pendant longtemps occupé
d'inspection du travail et de
surveillance à sûreté dans les m de
charbon du Nord de France et je sais ce
que c'est
oui monsieur Cochet
attendez allez monsieur Cochet
monsieur monsieur repusard merci je vais
compléter je vais compléter sur sur un
certain nombre de de questions est-ce
qu'une explosion nucléaire
est
possible je crois que alors d'abord les
explosion g que nous qui ont été vu et
pour certaines
spectaculaires n'ont pas mis en en cause
par elles-même la l'intégrité des
bâtiments nucléaires et ça c'est donc un
point très important pour la la
protection même si évidemment cette
intégrité peut être mise en cause Infiné
par la l'absence d'autres
refroidissement il y a c'est trop tôt de
dire si des réactions violentes se se
produiront ou pas en fonction des
scénarios et de la capacité ité à
rajouter suffisamment d'eau si on
rajoute suffisamment
d'eau l'exploitant pourra récupérer non
pas la sûreté des installation qui sera
qui seront de toute façon bon à mettre à
la poubelle mais au moins on pourra
stopper l'émanation de en tout cas la
limité fortement l'émanation de regjet
radioactif mais il y a des scénar des
scénarios plus violents qui sont tout à
fait
plausibles par exemple si la si les
combustibles fondu traverser la cuve il
finirait par arriver sur le sur le béton
hein qui est prévu avec une épaisseur
très importante sur les réacteurs
japonais japonais mais l'interaction
entre le combustible fondu et le béton
produira des grandes quantités de gaz et
donc ça sera spectaculaire ça serait
spectaculaire il faut souhaiter que les
mesures de de de PR non il y aura pas il
est peu il peut y avoir des explosions
locales mais mais il y aura pas une
bombe atomique des explosions à
caractère chimique d'e explosion
nucléaire il y aura pas voilà ça c'est
ça c'est acquis mais il peut y avoir des
des choses extrêmement spectaculaires
sur les images de télévision mais qui
reste d'ult trit comme le rappelle
Bernard Bigot d'un d'un d'interaction
chimique de la production de de gaz
extrêmement chaud qui peuvent localement
générer des des
explosions la protection sur 20 ou 30 km
est-elle suffisante c'est un point euh
d'abord qui relève de l'autorité de
sûreté japonaise et du gouvernement
japonais et donc nous devons être
prudents quand nous commentons cela ceci
dit les dans certains des scénarios que
que nous étudions avec nos nos collègues
américains en particulier euh il
s'avérerait que c'est cette zone serait
insuffisante mais encore une fois nous
devons être prudents et ne pas faire la
leçon indumement aux autorités
japonaises en tout cas la zone de Tokyo
en tout état de cause n'aura pas besoin
d'être considérée comme zone
contaminé avec des des mesures
extraordinaires et à forciori donc les
territoires français d'outrem ou la
métropole et si j'évoquais les si
j'évoquais les volontairement les la
pollution radiologique causée par les
essais d'armes nucléaaires c'était pour
éviter de poser le point des accidents
de Fukushima par rapport au point de
Tchernobyl
oui ben peut-être je ne sais pas chacun
peut s'exprimer il est trop tôt à mon
avis il est trop tôt de de de notre
point de vue pour positionner nous
savons que ça sera très largement
au-dessus de TMI puisqu'il y a pas eu de
J radioactif significatif donc l'autre
point de référence c'est tchernoby
est-ce que ça sera en dessous c'est
c'est tout à fait vraisemblable si les
mesur de de récupération qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure arrivve à leur terme dans
l'hypothèse inverse on pourrait imaginer
des rejet moins violents en un pic
tchernoby c'était un pic qui a
duré quinzaine de jours et puis c'est
monté très haut dans l'atmosphère et
cetera mais là nous pouvons avoir une
une diffusion plus longue euh avec
plusieurs cœur de et donc une
répartition dans le temps différente
mais aboutissant à une masse de césium
libéré dans l'atmosphère supérieure à ce
qui est à tchernobile c'est possible et
mais l'avenir nous le dira et tout
dépend encore des des succès et c'est
pour ça que madame leovergan monsieur
Bigot avait raison de souligner
l'urgence des euh des mesures de de de
temp destiné à récupérer autant que
possible la sûreté des installations
alors un dernier euh un dernier point
vous parliez du du la question été posée
du spectre des interventions de de l'ASN
et de l'IRSN c'est vrai que la l'ASN
couvre l'ensemble des installations
nucléaires civiles y compris les
installations médicales avec les mêmes
préoccupations de défense en profondeur
en de principes qui font de la Sûreté
Nucléaire et qui ont amené à une une
réévaluation forte par exemple dans le
domaine de la radiothérapie qui est
encore en cours actuellement euh et
quant à l'IRSN et bien il est l'appui
technique des pouvoirs publics en
général mais plus particulièrement de
l'ASN mais aussi de l'Autorité de sûreté
dééfense et donc l'expertise de l'IRSN
sert aussi à l'évaluation de la sûreté
du du domaine militaire qui s'agisse des
navires ou des usines qui contribuent à
le à la production à la maintenance des
armes et donc le nous appliquons ce sont
les mêmes experts et donc il y a pas
deux POS de mesure le nucléaire la
Sûreté Nucléaire
défense dans notre pays est conduite
avec la même philosophie que dans le
secteur civil ce qui ce qui
n'est ce qui est un avantage du point de
vue alors la transparence n'est pas la
même on peut comprendre les
préoccupations mais derrière je peux
vous garantir que ce sont les mêmes
calculs les mêmes codes de calcul la
même philosophie de défense en
profondeur qui est appliquée dans le
domaine de la
défense un dernier mot peut-être sur le
sur le sur laiaa la Ia n'a pas de n'a
que peu de pouvoir contraignant en
revanche elle a un un pouvoir
d'exemplarité elle contribue à la
transparence et les et les per review
c'est-à-dire les exercices qui
consistent à ce que des missions
internationales aillent dans les pays
respectifs et que les rapports soient
rendus publics ça c'est un outil
extrêmement puissant potentiellement
pour harmoniser par le haut les bonnes
pratiques et après des débuts hésitants
où les grands pays considéraent que
c'était pas pour eux je pense la France
a été la première à montrer l'exemple et
les États-Unis viennent de suivre de
même que la Russie donc c'est ce sont
des pratiques qui sont auxquel la France
a a contribué et qui sont extrêmement
utiles et nous sommes en train avec la
IEA de promouvoir le un travail du même
esprit sur les milieux d'expertise parce
qu'il y a les autorités de sûreté mais
les autorités sûreté se reposent dans
tous les pays sur des organismes
scientifiques qui sont plus ou moins
bien structurés la France est considéré
comme un très bon exemple et ces
infrastructures de sûreté qui dans les
nouveaux pays nucléaires ferait
gravement défaut parce que personne n'a
prévu de les financer aujourd'hui on
trouve l'argent pour construire des
réacteurs mais il y a pas d'argent pour
construire les autorités de sûreté on
peut trouver une autorité de sûreté mais
si elle a pas son backup scientifique et
technique son son son efficience sera
limitée et ça c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important enfin un dernier commentaire
si vous permettez sur le le sur
l'influence du du caractère privé ou pas
privé de l'exploitation des réacteurs je
je c'est un bon c'est un bon sujet mais
c'est un c'est un angle de de question
qui en fait n'est pas très pertinent la
question est de savoir dans un système
national comment qui P les risques et
qui comment euh le l'exploitant est
associé et le gouvernement comment les
décisions d'ordre national euh pèsent
sur les équilibres je je je m'explique
euh au Japon les conséquences de
l'accident seront financées par les
contribuables japonais et donc c'est un
c'est un point qui est qui serait vrai
dans tous les pays et la question est
donc que la sûreté doit primer quel que
soit son coût sur l'exploitant et donc
les les les débats sur la sur la sûreté
ne doivent pas être gouvernés par le le
le le le souci de l'équilibre financier
de l'exploitant dans n'importe quelles
condition ça c'est un point dans
politique je le mentionne parce que
c'est un paramètre de la sûreté mais il
naappartient pas à l'organ à l'IRSN de
le tranché mais je voulais attirer votre
attention sur le fait c'était une
question pertinente en matière de sûreté
non pas qu'il s'agisse de caractère
privé au public de l'exploitant mais de
la de l'équilibre économique et de la
vision économique qu'il y a derrière
l'exploitant de l'énergie nucléaire
c'est une question qui n'est pas sans
rapport avec la sûreté je vous remercie
Bernard Bigot sur les questions sûreté
voilà vous venez de suivre pendant plus
de 3h30 en direct l'audition de toute la
filière nucléaire française par les
députés et les sénateurs vous pouvez
d'ailleurs continuer à suivre cette
réunion sur notre canal 2424 alors on
rejoint tout de suite Fernand Tavares
qui est toujours en direct devant la
salle la Martine alors ferernand
beaucoup beaucoup de discussions mais
pas vraiment d'annonces fracassantees
non mais on a tout d'abord compris que
ce soit les élus sénateurs ou députés
mais aussi les invités tous les
responsables de la sûreté nucléaire en
France n'avit qu'une idée en tête tout
d'abord c'est priorité à ce qui se passe
au Japon c'est vraiment dramatique
certains ont dit catastrophique et il
faut vraiment trouver des solutions au
plus vite on a remarqué l'intervention
de la directrice de Areva Anne lvergon
qui a suggéré de balancer c'est le mot
qui convient 100 m³ d'eau à l'heure au
plus vite sur les sites touchés c'est la
seule façon de mettre fin à toute fusion
mais le problème c'est de trouver cette
eau les canaders Français ben il
mettraent trop de temps pour aller sur
sur place il faut trouver des solutions
àit soit par des bateaux pompes soit par
des camions de pompierers très bien et
qu'en est-il des conséquences sur la
filière française on sait que les vers
notamment y Cochet le député y Cochet a
beaucoup parlé lui ne veut plus entendre
parler du nucléaire mais ce n'est pas
vraiment le même son de cloche pour les
autres parties hein tous les
responsables de la sûreté nucléaire en
France sont d'accord pour qu'il y ait un
audit et un examen approfondi de chaque
site nucléaire en France d'autre part
transparence c'est un mot qui est revenu
plusieurs fois au cours de ces auditions
chacun dit ici et reconnaît qu'il faudra
communiquer au grand public le résultat
des examens à la hou de ces centrales
nucléaires car on entend dire déjà ici
ou là qu'il faudrait supprimer peut-être
telle ou telle centrale nucléaire en
France ça n'est en tout cas pour le
moment pas
d'actualité Fernand et nous reviendrons
bien sûr sur cette réunion dans nos
prochaines édition d'information à 19h
et à 20h30 ne les loupez pas merci de
nous avoir suivi et très bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires